bonjour à tous place ce matin un débat
qui s'est tenu hier après-midi dans
l'hémicycle un débat consacré à la
construction européenne
alors que doivent se tenir à dimanche
prochains dimanches 25 mai les élections
européennes
alors que ces élections peine à
intéresser alors que l'abstention
s'annonce record alors que l'euro
scepticisme grandit le sénat a décidé de
consacrer cette semaine deux débats
l'europe avec hier donc ce débat
consacré aux perspectives de l'union a
pu aujourd'hui un débat consacré au
climat et à l'énergie alors faut-il plus
d'intégration européenne comme le
réclame le socialiste richard yung qui
veut une véritable union politique au
contraire à ce que l'euroscepticisme
ambiant découlent directement et je cite
jean pierre chevènement de déni de
démocratie de 2005 comment redonner du
souffle et de l'inspiration au projet
européen tout de suite retour à ce débat
qui s'est tenu hier après-midi dans
l'hémicycle
l'ordre du jour appelle donc le débat
sur les perspectives de la construction
européenne c'est une demande de la
commission des affaires européennes et
je vais donner la parole à monsieur
simon sutour président de la commission
des affaires européennes chers collègues
vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente
mes chers collègues je veux félicite de
la tenue de ce débat et je veux
remercier tout particulièrement le
président du sénat et la conférence des
présidents de l'avoir inscrit à notre
ordre du jour je remercie aussi monsieur
le ministre de sa disponibilité pour cet
échange qui arrive à un moment
particulièrement important
nous sommes en effet à quelques jours
d'un scrutin qui va donner une nouvelle
composition au parlement européen depuis
le traité de lisbonne celui ci joue un
rôle essentiel de codécideur dans de
très nombreux domaines le choix des
citoyens européens ce sera donc
déterminant pour l'orientation des
politiques dans les 100 prochaines
années
pour la première fois les citoyens
pèseront directement sur le choix du
président de la commission européenne
mais pourquoi ne pas le dire ce scrutin
intervient dans un climat morose pour le
projet européenne l'europe apparaît trop
souvent comme le bouc émissaire
elle serait responsable de tous les
problèmes les dysfonctionnements sont
amplement souligné commenté en revanche
les réalisations sont trop souvent
passée sous silence
pourtant quelques 14 millions
d'européens ont profité de la libre
circulation pour s'installer dans un
autre état membre le programme erasmus a
bénéficié à plus de 3 millions
d'étudiants depuis sa création la pac
c'est chaque année quelques 10 milliards
d'euros pour notre agriculture
la politique de cohésion ce sera 14
milliard d'euros au profit de nos
territoires
et même si certains voudraient que l'on
n'ignore désormais cette réalité la
construction européenne a permis et
c'est vraiment essentiel a permis à
notre continent de vivre en paix de
façon durable nous devons leur dire en
particulier aux jeunes générations
comment par ailleurs imaginer répondre
aux défis de la mondialisation sent
confortée l'union européenne
malheureusement c'est le sens du projet
européen qui s'est effiloché au fil du
temps les pères fondateurs de l'europe
était animé par une vision qui fait
défaut aujourd'hui et nos concitoyens
ressentent ce manque
c'est pourquoi ils commencent à douter
ce doute ne peut que faire le lit de
tous les populismes
il est de notre devoir de le combattre
en redonnant à ce grand projet toute sa
dimension
nous le devons aux jeunes qui doivent
vivre l'europe comme une chance et non
comme une menace
au sein de la commission des affaires
européennes nous avons donc jugé
nécessaire de mener une réflexion
approfondie sur les perspectives de la
construction européenne
notre collègue pierre bernard émond que
je salue tout particulièrement a bien
voulu se charger de conduire cet effet
il a fait avec la foi d'un européen
convaincu et expérimentée mais pas dupe
eu des ratés de la construction
européenne son rapport est très complet
il est argumentée et fait des constats
lucide il formule des propositions
pertinentes même si certaines
demanderont du temps avant d'entrer dans
la réalité son rapport a suscité un
débat approfondi au sein de notre
commission et recueilli une approbation
unanime de la part de tous nos collègues
qu'est l'europe voulons nous
c'est bien la première question à
laquelle nous devons répondre
nous pouvons au préalable dire quelle
europe ne voulons pas ne pouvons pas
accepter que les peuples subissent les
conséquences des errements de la finance
dans 30 états membres les populations
dans le supporter des politiques
d'austérité qui vise à réparer les
manquements graves de quelques heures
nous ne pouvons laisser se développer le
chômage et la précarité sans réagir en
effet quel peut être l'avenir d'un
continent dans lequel le chômage
continuerait à toucher plus de 25% des
jeunes comme c'est le cas dans beaucoup
d'états maman oui le rétablissement des
comptes publics est indispensable oui il
faut réduire l'endettement abyssal qui
obère les perspectives d'avenir mais
l'assainissement budgétaire doit
impérativement se conjuguer avec des
politiques ambitieuses au service de la
croissance les peuples peuvent accepter
des efforts mais il faut leur donner des
motifs d'espérer il est possible de
promouvoir une politique alternative à
l'austérité nous voulons une europe plus
sociale qui investit davantage lutte
contre le chômage et pour
l'harmonisation fiscale
c'est là que sont les attentes des
citoyens européens touchés par la crise
nous devons bâtir une europe qui protège
mieux les droits sociaux et les libertés
fondamentales
gardons-nous aussi de diviser les
européens il n'y a pas d'un côté une
europe du nord qui se répare paraît de
toutes les vertus et de l'autre une
europe du sud qui sera figé de toutes
les turpitudes
la france porte ce message en europe
depuis 2012 et sous son impulsion
l'action pour la croissance est
redevenue une priorité l'emploi des
jeunes a été inscrit à l'agenda européen
8 milliard d'euros ont été débloqués par
le conseil européen pour apporter des
réponses à ce défi majeur la france a
aussi joué un rôle moteur pour qu'un
texte soit adopté afin de lutter plus
efficacement contre le véritable dumping
social qui est pratiqué à travers le
détachement des travailleurs notre
commission avait alerté en avril 2013
sur ses pratiques dans un rapport très
argumentée de notre collègue éric
bocquet le sénat avait adopté une
résolution demandant qu'il y soit mis un
terme nous avons aussi voté une
proposition de loi récemment pour
combattre plus efficacement les fraudes
nous n'aurons pas un espace commence à
l'harmonisation fiscale mais aussi
harmonisation sociale
l'annoncé de la création d'un smic en
allemagne dans le cadre de l'accord de
grande coalition va dans le bon sens
mais il faut aller plus loin et
s'engager sur la voie d'une véritable
harmonisation en europe l'europe doit
aussi retrouver le sens des grands
projets seuls peuvent dessiner l'avenir
de façon positive elle a su le faire
dans le passé chacun garde en effet à
l'esprit le succès d'airbus ou encore le
processus de bologne pour l'enseignement
supérieur c'est à l'échelle européenne
que de grands projets peuvent avoir un
effet de levier sur la croissance
économique
c'est ensemble que nous pourrons réunir
les moyens d'entrer de plein pied dans
l'économie numérique
le rapport d'information de notre
collègue catherine morin desailly
l'avait parfaitement montré l'europe ne
doit pas devenir la colonie numérique
la protection des données personnelles
est une garantie essentielle que nous
devons aux citoyennes le scandales
récents d'espionnage américain à grande
échelle résonne comme une piqûre de
rappel
l'europe doit conforter son propre
modèle de protection des données et le
défendre au plan international j'avais
souligné cette exigence ici même à ma
qualité de rapporteur lorsque nous avons
examiné il ya deux ans maintenant la
proposition de réforme de madame viviane
reding les révélations inquiétantes de
ces derniers mois ne peuvent hélas que
conforter cette analyse de même la crise
ukrainienne est aussi là pour nous
rappeler que l'union européenne aurait
tout intérêt à intégrer davantage ses
politiques énergétiques dans ce domaine
plus encore que dans d'autres avancées
un autre dispersé c'est affaiblir la
position de l'union européenne mais
aussi celle de chaque état membre face à
nos portes à nos partenaires des états
tiers mais pouvons-nous réaliser ses
ambitions dans une europe à 28 ou les
intérêts souvent divergents et où le
sens du projet européen n'est pas
toujours défini de façon identique
le rapport de pierre bernard émond a un
immense mérite celui de poser clairement
la question
il ne s'agit pas d'exclure certaines
mais il s'agit de savoir qui veut
réellement avancer dans le sens d'une
véritable ambition européenne une
ambition qui laisse de côté les égoïsmes
nationaux et qui affirme clairement les
valeurs d'intégration et de solidarité
dans le passé les coopérations
renforcées au surmonter les blocages
souvent en dehors des traités comme pour
schengen ou l'interconnexion des casiers
judiciaires
dans le cadre des traités purée ça plus
récemment avec le règlement des divorces
transfrontaliers
ou le brevet de l'union mais n'ayant pas
peur de laisser les états qui le veulent
agir pour approfondir le projet européen
les autres pourront les suivre
ultérieure non plus d'intégration doit
être recherchée au sein de la zone euro
nous avons beaucoup réformer sa
gouvernance au cours des dernières
années
l'union bancaire prend enfin forme la
coordination des politiques économiques
et budgétaires a beaucoup progressé
même s'il est légitime de débattre de la
forme et du rythme de cette coordination
pour construire cette europe puissance
nous avons rénové les institutions
européennes il faut les rendre plus
crédible et plus vite
il faut aussi un budget à la hauteur des
ambitions on ne peut plus continuer avec
un budget européen aussi faible qui ne
dépasse pas les 140 3 milliards d'euros
en 2014
sur les villes du pays mais pour
l'augmenter il faut retrouver la lettre
et l'esprit des traités en défi en
définissant de nouvelles ressources
propres
sous l'impulsion du parlement européen
un groupe de travail inter
institutionnelle a été créé il est
présidé par
mario monti et nous étudions ces
propositions avec attention
l'union devra aussi affirmer une
ambition en matière de politique
étrangère et de défense dans un monde
incertain comme nous le rappelle le
conte fils craignant les européens
doivent unir leurs voix et leurs forces
pour peser dans les affaires du monde
nous voulons aussi une europe plus
démocratique où les citoyens puissent
exprimer clairement leur choix avec un
réel pouvoir de contrôler la composition
du parlement européenne doit évoluer il
faut corriger les inégalités de
représentation qui nuisent à la
légitimité démocratique
mais nous parlements nationaux avant
aussi un rôle essentiel pour rapprocher
les citoyens de l'europe le traité de
lisbonne nous confier un rôle important
pour le contrôle de subsidiarité
je dois dire que nous l'exerçons très
sérieusement au niveau du sénat et c'est
un progrès essentiels à deux reprises
les parlements nationaux ont adressé un
carton jaune à la commission européenne
celle-ci a retiré un texte qui pouvait
mettre en cause le droit de grève
c'était ce qu'on appelait le monty 2 le
droit de grève des travailleurs détachés
et c'est à l'initiative de notre
commission que plus d'un tiers des
parlements nationaux a eu la même
opposition que nous et la commission
devait réexaminer son texte l'a
tellement bien réexaminer qu'elle l'a
retirée
elle a maintenu par contre son texte sur
le parquet européenne mais indiqué que
les avis des parlements nationaux
seraient pris en compte dans la
discussion du texte
ce contrôle de subsidiarité permet aux
parlements nationaux de s'opposer à une
action qui ne jugent pas justifié nous
devons aller plus loin beaucoup plus
loin un droit d'initiative un droit
d'initiative nous permettrait de
proposer de façon positive des actions à
mener au niveau de l'union européenne
droit d'initiative des parlements
nationaux
les parlements nationaux sont
progressivement associés aux procédures
de contrôle pour un nombre croissant de
politique en matière économique et
financière une conférence a été mise en
place par le traité sur la stabilité la
coordination et la gouvernance au sein
de l'union économique et monétaire un
comité mixte assure le contrôle des
politiques étrangère et de défense cette
association sera prochainement établie
pour le contrôle d'europol et
l'évaluation d'eurojust les parlements
nationaux doivent se saisir de ces
opportunités pour mieux contrôler ce qui
se passe à bruxelles
pour conclure mes chers collègues madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre je
veux à nouveau me féliciter que le sénat
et se débat aujourd'hui l'europe est un
grand projet ce projet a permis des
avancées considérables les
dysfonctionnements existent certes il
faut les identifier lucidement les jeter
enfin les bases d'une nouvelle ambition
c'est ainsi que nous dessinerons
l'europe que nous voulons une europe
proche de vos concitoyens et qui
répondent à leurs attentes
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président surtout
quand la parole est à monsieur pierre
bernard-reymond rapporteur de la
commission des affaires européennes vous
avez la parole chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires européennes mes
chers collègues
vivons-nous une simple crise
financière économique sociale morale né
aux états unis et qui a déferlé sur le
monde en particulier sur l'europe qui
n'ayant pas achevé sa construction n'a
pas eu immédiatement à sa disposition
tous les instruments nécessaires pour y
répondre
ne sommes nous pas plutôt à loeb d'une
grande mutation
caractérisée par l'explosion
démographique l'évolution climatique
l'émergence de nouvelles puissances sur
fond de mondialisation
qui va pendant plusieurs décennies
rebattre les cartes avant de retrouver
une nouvelle stabilité et un nouvel
ordre du monde dont aucune nation ne
peut dire aujourd'hui quelle place elle
y occupera
ou bien troisième hypothèse
ce petit cap de l'asie l'europe qui
depuis plus de 2000 ans à forger une
civilisation en apportant au monde les
valeurs de liberté de progrès de
solidarité cette europe là at-elle
amorcé son déclin
le bas empire européen at il commencé
ces interrogations cette peur n'explique
tel par confusément en partie la
radicalisation du débat dont nous sommes
les témoins à l'occasion de ces
élections européennes
explique t'elle pas l'hostilité le
désamour ou l'indifférence que nous
constatons à l'égard de l'europe
entre ceux qui face à ce défi veulent à
nouveau se réfugier sur la seule nation
et ceux qui sont partisans de la fuite
en avant vers un super état ont ce don
l'horizon se résume à une échéance
électorale et qui s'efforcent chacun en
ce qui les concerne de concilier des
contraires nous percevons bien que le
trouble profond que crée cette existence
des différents avenirs possibles et elle
au cours des siècles notre continent
s'est organisé d'abord sous la forme de
l'impérialisme c'est à dire de la
domination des peuples par l'un d'entre
eux puis en réaction a été inventé la
nation que l'on a paré de toutes les
vertus jusqu'à ce que l'on constate que
le nationalisme avait aussi donné deux
guerres mondiales dont le 100e
anniversaire de la première nous
rappelle l'atrocité
de ces atrocités répéter aînés
l'intuition historique des pères
fondateurs de l'europe qui en proposant
de transcender les nations sans les
effacer on proposait la lente maturation
la construction d'une communauté de
nations fondé sur la libre adhésion la
démocratie la solidarité le progrès et
la recherche constante de la paix cette
paix fut le premier défi il a été gagné
la paix règne au sein de l'union
européenne depuis presque 70 ans le
deuxième défi lui aussi a été relevé
celui de la réunification du continent
les pays qui ont décidé d'abandonner la
dictature en grèce en espagne au
portugal puis ceux qui ont été libérés
par l'implosion de l'urss sont venus
nous rejoindre
auparavant ceux qui doutaient de la
pertinence et de la clairvoyance de
cette démarche de dépassement les pays
nordiques le royaume uni en était venu à
penser qu'en définitive il valait mieux
être dedans que dehors
le troisième grand défi qui se présente
maintenant devant nous et celui de la
mondialisation et d'une façon générale
de la façon dont nous allons aborder et
gérer les profondes transformations et
convulsions auquel nous devons nous
attendre la tâche ne sera pas facile
mais la question est simple vaut-il
mieux aborder ce défi seul ou à
plusieurs
le contexte qui nous attend appelle la
réponse en 1950
c'était hier la population mondiale
comptait 2 milliard et demi d'habitants
en 2050
elle dépassera 9 milliards c'est la plus
grande révolution de tous les temps qui
se développe presque dans l'indifférence
d'ici là tous les continents verront
leur population augmenter sauf l'europe
qui passera de 530 millions d'habitants
en 2030 à 515 millions en 2050 à cette
époque aucun pays de l'union européenne
ne représentera 1 % de cette population
mondiale et dès 2030 aucun pays de
l'union ne figurera plus dans l'es8
première puissance du monde
devant de tels faits on pense aux
proverbes touareg seul on va plus vite
ensemble on va plus loin
voulons nous être encore demain des
acteurs de l'organisation de la planète
voulons-nous il défendre nos valeurs nos
intérêts notre niveau de vie et notre
qualité de vie ou bien usé fatigué
désabusé divisée allons nous nous
contenter d'en être les spectateurs
replié sur chacune de nos nations livrés
à la puissance d'état continent
j'espère que nous sommes nombreux en
france et en europe à vouloir relever ce
troisième grand défi après celui de la
paix et de la réunification
le défi de notre participation à
l'élaboration du destin de la planète et
de la défense de nos valeurs et de nos
intérêts les résultats des élections du
25 mai prochain nous montreront
certainement que ce défi n'est pas gagné
il n'est pas perdu non plus le désamour
actuel à l'égard de l'europe est réelle
et en grande partie explicable
on peut lui trouver de nombreuses causes
qui dictent autant de remèdes et
d'inflexion la crise financière née aux
états unis de l'ultralibéralisme d'un
capitalisme non régulés a provoqué
beaucoup de chômage et beaucoup de
souffrances sans que l'europe ne soit
apparue comme protectrice face à cette
vague la plupart des chefs d'état et des
hommes politiques n'ont pas osé dire
pendant longtemps à leurs peuples que
les trente glorieuses était terminée et
que l'on ne pourrait plus vivre tout à
fait comme avant ils ont camouflé cette
réalité en endettant leur pays ce qui
rend beaucoup plus difficile voire
impossible au niveau de chaque état une
relance qui serait pourtant nécessaire
les bulles financières en irlande et
immobilière en espagne ont prospéré
jusqu'à leur éclatement et jusqu'à ce
que l'europe se dote bien tard de règles
de régulation et d'une surveillance
bancaire qui n'existaient pas jusqu'ici
quant aux règles budgétaires elles ont
été transgressés peu de temps avoir été
élaborée la facilité a consisté
également dans chaque état à s'attribuer
ce qui fonctionnait bien et a rejeté sur
l'europe bouc émissaire tout ce qui
n'allait pas l'évolution des pratiques
de gouvernance n'est certainement pas
allé non plus dans le sens d'une
meilleure qualité les horizons
politiques se sont considérablement
raccourci la prochaine élection plutôt
que la prochaine génération et les
pratiques de l'action politique forment
aujourd'hui un quart est tragique fait
essentiellement de sondages de marketing
de tactique électorale et de
communication au détriment de la
réflexion à long terme des valeurs et du
courage politique les chefs d'état qui
prennent tous goût à l'exercice du
pouvoir c'est légitime éprouve beaucoup
de mal à déléguer une partie de leur
souveraineté
la politique de chacun d'eux devrait
reposer sur deux piliers le
développement économique et la
construction de l'europe ce n'est pas
l'impression que nous avons en ce qui
concerne le pilier de l'europe et cela
dans tous les pays de l'union les hommes
politiques qui vante l europe il ya
encore quelques années n'ose plus en
parler devant la montée du nationalisme
du populisme et du séparatisme
avec qui certains sont tentés de
composer la presse dans son ensemble
juge que la question de l'europe ne fait
pas recette sur les antennes et entre
deux élections ne s'intéresse à l'europe
qu'à travers les dérapages de la
commission je remercie public sénat pour
la retransmission du débat entre les
principaux candidats à la présidence de
la commission et j'appelle de mes voeux
la tenue d'une telle émission tous les
semestres la gestion de la commission
est apparu souvent à juste titre comme
trop lointaine trop tatillonne trop
technocratique et souvent maladroite
s'abandonnant à une inflation normative
devenu parfois ridicules parfois
insupportable alors que par ailleurs un
travail important a été accompli comme
le prouve par exemple l'oeuvre accomplie
par michel barnier la politique
commerciale a souvent donné l'impression
d'une certaine naïveté à l'égard de nos
concurrents de même que l'absence d'une
politique de change contribuant à un
euro fort qui ne représente pas que des
inconvénients
certes est ressentie essentiellement
comme un obstacle à nos exportations la
politique de concurrence dans l'union
apparaît aussi parfois comme une entrave
à la constitution de grands groupes en
mesure d'exister face aux géants de la
concurrence internationale mais surtout
la démocratie en europe est largement
inachevé le président du conseil
européen est nommé et non élu alors que
l'europe a besoin comme toutes les
grandes puissances d'une voix d'un
visage et d'un patron le président de la
commission sera désigné par le conseil
certes en tenant compte du résultat des
élections européennes du moins
l'espère-t-on puis avalisé par le
parlement quant au mode d'élection des
parlementaires il conduit à ce que les
électeurs ne les voit au mieux qu'une
fois tous les cinq ans le couple franco
allemand qui a été le moteur de l'europe
est aujourd'hui profondément
déséquilibré au niveau des performances
économiques au niveau de la politique
énergétique au niveau des perspectives
démographiques la faiblesse du budget
européen est également un grave handicap
1% du pnb européen
comparée aux 25 % du budget fédéral des
etats-unis certes il ne s'agit pas de
faire l'europe sur le modèle américain
mais un budget de 1 % du pnb pose
incontestablement un problème de
crédibilité
ceci est d'autant plus regrettable que
c'est une politique de désendettement
est absolument nécessaire au niveau de
chacun de nos états elle ne l'est pas au
niveau de l'europe puisque celle ci qui
n'a pas le droit d'emprunter n'est donc
par définition pas endetté c'est à ce
niveau européen que l'on aurait dû faire
la relance mais les états ne l'ont pas
voulu la méthode intergouvernementale
quant à elle est à bout de souffle la
règle de l'unanimité en usage dans corps
dans bien des domaines retardent et
édulcore les décisions à prendre
décision évidemment plus difficile à
prendre reconnaissons le à 28k cif en
france les pro européens sont séparés
par le mur de la bipolarisation et ont
tendance chacun de leur côté à prêter de
plus en plus une oreille très attentive
à la démagogie des extrêmes mais
peut-être plus que tout c'est la
coexistence de deux conceptions
fondamentales différentes de l'europe
qui pose problème
l'europe espace prônée par le royaume
uni qui s'accommode du seul marché
unique et d'une politique
transatlantique et l'europe puissance
qui rassemble des partenaires qui
souhaitent davantage d'intégration à
terme une europe à visée fédéral et qui
ambitionne par exemple que l'on fasse
plus de place à des politiques communes
telles l'europe sociale il faut
réorganiser la cohabitation de ces deux
europes en conservant si possible les 28
pays dans l'union mais en faisant en
sorte que ceux qui veulent aller plus
vite et plus loin au besoin selon des
rythmes différenciés puissent le faire
sans être entravée par ceux qui
n'adhèrent pas à la vision d'une europe
plus intégrée
ces derniers doivent lancer un véritable
appel d'offres pour plus d'intégration
ce diagnostic s'il est partagé nous
tracent le chemin nous dicte le projet
dans le rapport que j'ai eu l'honneur de
présenter en commission et dans lequel
je le reconnais j'ai davantage affirmer
une conviction que cherchait une
impossible synthèse
j'ai présenté j'ai articulé 24
propositions bien sûr toutes doivent
être soumises à discussion à
concertation à amélioration certaine
disparaîtront il faudra du temps
certainement beaucoup de temps pour
qu'elle entre éventuellement dans le
droit positif mais j'estime qu'il est
important qu'après ces élections
l'europe soit à nouveau doté d'un grand
projet d'une grande ambition
susceptible de rassembler une majorité
d'européens il est important que les
chefs d'état à défaut d'homme d'état
cesse de louvoyer de ne s'intéresser
qu'au futur proche et à des politiques
réactive et sectorielles dont
l'efficacité serait démultiplié si elle
était intégrée à un plan d'ensemble et à
une vision à long terme il suffirait que
quelques chefs d'état de l'union le
président de la commission et quelques
commissaires le président du parlement
soit des visionnaires courageux plutôt
que des tacticiens frileux pour que
l'europe se réconcilie avec elle-même et
entraîne à nouveau les peuples vers un
projet fédérateur
l'europe doit être un projet de
civilisation
servi par une puissance
organisé à terme sur le mode du
fédéralisme pour forger une communauté
de nations ce projet pour l'europe
devrait franchir une nouvelle étape
démocratique renforcer sa capacité de
gouvernance et développer son économie
pour promouvoir avec beaucoup plus
d'efficacité de nouvelles politiques
sociales fiscales
énergétiques climatiques numérique tant
il est vrai que l'europe sera politique
ou ne sera plus il faudra renforcer
également la convergence et l'efficacité
des politiques étrangère et de défense
faire élire le président du conseil
européen par tous les parlementaires
d'europe députés sénateurs
parlementaires européens soit plus de
dix mille personnes dans un premier
temps avant l'élection au suffrage
universel faire élire le président de la
commission directement par le parlement
européen
dirar chizé cette commission comme un
gouvernement en désignant des hauts
commissaires des commissaires des
commissaires délégué promouvoir un mode
de scrutin uniforme et garantissant une
proximité de l'élu avec le citoyen pour
désigner les parlementaires européens
conférer davantage de pouvoirs au
parlement en lui faisant partager une
partie du pouvoir d'initiative
aujourd'hui entièrement aux mains de la
commission et en lui conférant le droit
de voter dans certaines limites une
partie des recettes mieux associer les
parlements nationaux à la conduite des
affaires européennes pourrait constituer
me semble-t-il un programme
d'approfondissement de la démocratie
dans les années à venir sur le plan
économique doter à nouveau le budget
européen de ressources propres à hauteur
de 60% d'ici 10 ans doubler le montant
du budget dans la même période autorisée
l'europe a emprunté en lui appliquant
néanmoins les règles de maestri ch créer
des eurobonds dès lors que les
productivité des différents états
convergeraient
confié la politique des changes à la
banque centrale européenne
c'est elle qui a sauvé l'euro réformer
la cour des comptes européenne en lui
donnant des responsabilités des analyses
plus affirmée à l'instar de notre propre
cour des comptes sont autant de mesures
qui me semble-t-il serait elle aussi en
mesure d'accroître collectivement notre
capacité et notre intégration économique
oui l'europe est au milieu du gué
je crois profondément que c'est en amont
que c'est en étant davantage européens
que nous pourrons rester
souverain
l'évolution du monde nous interpelle le
défi ne sera relevé qu'avec imagination
et courage et comme le disait john
maynard keynes la difficulté n'est pas
de comprendre les idées nouvelles mais
d'échapper aux idées anciennes il ne
s'agit pas de faire la révolution où le
grand bond en avant mais il s'agit de ne
plus tergiverser
il s'agit de sortir du clair obscur de
sa gras de s'affranchir des égoïsmes
nationaux de dessiner un projet et de
tracer un chemin
face au gigantesque défi que nous lance
le 21e siècle
la nation ne peut demeurer le stade
ultime de l'organisation des peuples les
provinces ont fait la france aujourd'hui
les états doivent faire l'europe s'en
défaire les nations
merci monsieur le rapporteur dans la
suite du débat la parole est maintenant
aux orateurs des groupes le premier
monsieur andré gattolin du groupe
écologiste chaque collègue vous avez la
parole
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous ne
sommes plus qu'à quelques jours des
élections européennes
et pourtant c'est un peu comme si ces
dernières n'existait pas l'exemple du
débat qui oppose et le 15 mai dernier
dernier les prétendants à la présidence
de la commission européenne est à cet
égard assez emblématique non seulement
les grandes chaînes n'ont pas voulu le
diffuser mais l'une d'entre elles la
principale antennes du service public a
mis en place un programme concurrent
certes consacré à l'euro mais sans aucun
des candidats en lice sur son plateau
france 2 entendez faire de l'info
audiences plutôt que faire de
l'information citoyenne ceux qui
notamment parmi des politiques avait osé
critiquer cette impasse allez voir ce
qu'ils allaient voir selon les dires de
la chaîne et bien ce fut tout vu ses
terrasses de programme de campagne n'a
recueilli que 7,7 pour cent de parts de
marché une des plus faibles audiences de
l'histoire de la chaîne c'est avec la
même désinvolture que france télévisions
et ses consoeurs privé se sont
abstraites déséquilibre de temps de
parole dur dur durant la phase de
précampagne obligeant d'ailleurs la
semaine passée le csa et son président à
procéder un sérieux rappel à l'ordre ces
manquements à leurs obligations de nos
grands médias démontre s'il le fallait
encore la justesse de l'initiative
approuvée par le sénat de notre collègue
pierre bernard-reymond de soutenir la
création d'une radio france europe voué
à informer de manière récurrente nos
concitoyens sur l'europe
j'en profite ici pour saluer son
engagement européen sans faille sur
lequel au delà de nos différences
politiques jeu rejoins totalement cette
assemblée ne serait pas tout à fait la
même sans la voix de ce grand
fédéraliste les européens tels que lui
en france sont encore trop peu nombreux
car les lacunes de la classe politique
non sur ces questions rien à envier à
celle observée chez nombre de nos médias
les responsables nationaux cette souvent
à cette trop facile plantations se
défausser sur l'europe pour masquer
leurs propres erreurs ou leur absence de
véritable vision politique il est si
facile de blâmer des institutions
lointaine et forcément complexe en
raison de leur fonctionnement de leur
localisation de le cas de leur caractère
polyglotte et des tâches ingrates on
veut bien leur confier alors l'europe
n'était évidemment pas parfaite telle
qu'elle existe aujourd'hui elle est même
foncièrement vicié inachevé
elle est loin d'être suffisamment
démocratique lisible et efficace
c'est d'autant plus difficile à accepter
que le monde évolue très vite que
l'europe semble elle faire du surplace
dans 30 ans comme l'a rappelé mon
collègue pierre bernard-reymond plus
aucun état de l'union ne sera membre du
g8 alors qu ils sont quatre aujourd'hui
à y figurer c'est évidemment une source
d'inquiétude et d'exigence cette
exigence qui n'est pas propre à la
france est aussi la résultante d'un
autre trait commun qui renvoie à nos
valeurs partagées les européens ont soif
de progrès de liberté de démocratie
or au delà de l'union européenne
elle-même
ce sont ces notion même de progrès de
liberté de solidarité de démocratie qui
sont aujourd'hui en crise comment
l'europe qui s'est construite dès ses
origines en tapant tentant d'articuler
ses attentes pourrait-elle échapper à
ces difficultés et à ses questionnements
alors on part à présent l'abbé sieyès
jeu résumait ainsi la situation que nous
vivons aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
l'europe tout cas tel était jusqu'à
présent dans l'ordre politique
rien que demande-t-elle à y devenir
quelque chose
l'europe c'est une formidable rupture
historique volontaire et pacificatrice
c'est une aventure visant à réunir des
peuples qui par delà leurs frontières
leur langue leurs coutumes respectives
partagent déjà l'essentiel
l'europe aujourd'hui c'est la première
puissance économique mondiale est le
plus grand espace démocratique commun
après l'inde le brassage de ces
populations se voient tous les niveaux
de la société dans tous nos pays
aujourd'hui le premier ministre français
et la maire de paris sont d'origine
espagnole le président de l'assemblée
nationale est d'origine italienne
ce sont là des illustrations de ce que
l'europe en dépit de ses faiblesses est
bel et bien unie dans sa diversité
qu'elle constitue une part essentielle
de notre identité collective mais au
lieu de l'assumer les gouvernements
successifs sont passés maîtres dans
l'art de pousser toujours plus loin une
certaine intégration européenne tout en
cherchant à en minimiser l'aspect
fédérale démocratique politique la
commission européenne est condamné pour
ses orientations libérales mais on
oublie de dire que ce sont les
orientations des gouvernements réunis au
sein du conseil qu'elle sert le
parlement européen est critiqué pour son
impuissance politique mais ce sont les
états qui veulent à toute force
restreinte son pouvoir législatif
l'opacité dans laquelle se négocie
actuellement le projet de traité trois
authentiques est un véritable déni de
démocratie
ceci n'est plus possible monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues le débat du 15 mai dernier en
dépit de son insuffisante médiatisation
a constitué une première historique
certains ont parlé dans push
démocratique lorsque les candidats ont
l'un après l'autre prévenu les
gouvernements que ce processus
démocratique d'un genre nouveau
s'imposerait tu as eu et qu'il devrait
choisir comme président de la commission
celui ou celle qui aurait réuni une
majorité européenne sur son nom alors
attendons encore de savoir si les cinq
conjurer tiendront bon face aux oukases
de tel ou tel chef d'état ou de
gouvernement mais c'est bel et bien un
mini serment du jeu de paume que nous
avons assisté dans la sur dix ans
indifférence des responsables politiques
nationaux
les pensées qui mène le monde arrive sur
des pattes de colomb écrivait un grand
philosophe si nous sommes cohérents avec
nous même si nous voulons donner à
l'europe de nouvelles perspectives nous
devons nous joindre à ce serment et
l'appuyer dans les faits il ne tient
qu'à nous de sortir de l'ornière dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons non pas en
sortant de l'europe de l'euro mais en
complétant l'union n'ont pas en donnant
plus de poids aux états ou à je ne sais
quel marché intérieur mais en rendant
les institutions européennes plus
démocratique et en améliorant les
interactions entre niveau européen et
niveau national par exemple en deux
temps le parlement européen le cas
échéant appuyé sur les parlements
nationaux d'un véritable pouvoir
d'initiative législative en déconnectant
la citoyenneté européenne de la sole et
strict notion de nationalité en créant
pour 2019 une circonscription
transnationales sur laquelle serait élu
une partie des députés pour que ces
élections européennes celles qui
viennent soit les dernières à se faire
uniquement à l'échelon national ou
infranational nous sommes déjà européen
sur le plan économique historique et
culturel mais nous n'assumons pas encore
de l'être sur le plan politique c'est
pourtant en franchissant ce pas décisif
que nous donnerons enfin vie à l'europe
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues pour le groupe ump
donne la parole à monsieur jean bizet
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
en cette année de commémoration du
centenaire de la gorge de la guerre de
1914 et alors que l'ukraine sont
dangereusement dans la guerre civile le
projet européen a plus que jamais du
sens et doit être l'objet de tout notre
intérêt et de tous nos soins le rapport
de notre collègue pierre bernard reymond
qui le support de notre débat
aujourd'hui nous le rappelle très
utilement comme d'ailleurs le rapport du
président jean arthuis sur l'avenir de
la zone euro en 2012 certes la défiance
de nos concitoyens vis-à-vis de l'europe
augmentent sous l'effet de la crise or
c'est pour cette raison exactement que
nous devons continuer consolider ce qui
a été élaboré depuis 55 57 ans avec
patience et détermination
jamais la construction d'un espace
européen commun n'a été un long fleuve
tranquille
pas plus hier qu'aujourd'hui et il n'y a
aucune raison valable pour que nous nous
en relation l'union européenne est un
processus en perpétuelle évolution
sous le choc de la crise elle est au
milieu du gué et il est de notre
responsabilité de lui donner un nouvel
élan nos concitoyens ne doivent pas se
laisser séduire par les sirènes des
extrémistes ou des eurosceptiques pire
bernard lem raymond l'a expliqué encore
avec force ce qui est en jeu aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas l'europe elle-même à
laquelle la majorité continue d'adhérer
mais son fonctionnement nous devons
consolider ses succès combler ces
manques et résoudre ses faiblesses dans
un cadre collégiale et démocratique oui
mes chers collègues l'europe est
toujours un projet enthousiasmant qui
est déjà de nombreux succès à son actif
permettez moi de le rappeler brièvement
d'abord les valeurs de paix les valeurs
de liberté de dignité de solidarité qui
anime intrinsèquement le projet européen
le légitimerait à elle seule malgré les
interrogations du moment les jeunes
générations ont tendance à l'oublier
mais la construction européenne a sorti
le continent de guerre régulière qui à
deux reprises ont débouché sur une
conflagration mondiale
la consolider la sortie de la guerre
froide et accueilli l'est du continent
dans la démocratie elle nous a ouvert
les uns aux autres grâce à la liberté de
circulation
et on remarquable programme d échanges
entre étudiants je veux parler d'erasmus
de même le succès des politiques
communes que sont la politique agricole
commune et la politique commerciale
même si elles doivent s'adapter à la
nouvelle donne économique mondiale
constituent de solides acquis enfin d'un
point de vue économique l'union
européenne plus grand marché du monde
andré gattolin via me rappeler un
instant sa valeur commerciale est en
excédent ses parts dans le marché
mondial sont stables autour de 16% elle
présente un surplus industrielle et une
réelle compétitivité en matière de
services il ya donc pas douter du succès
économique de l'union européenne surtout
ce serait une catastrophe d'abandonner
l'euro générateur de confiance de faible
inflation et de stabilité des prix
l'euro à d'abord supprimer le risque de
changer le coût des transactions
monétaires c'est aujourd'hui la deuxième
monnaie la plus échangée au monde et la
deuxième monnaie de réserve
sortir de l'euro et revenir à une
monnaie nationale dévaloriser
signifie une hausse immédiate des taux
d'intérêt un renchérissement du coût de
la dette publique cela entraînerait une
dévaluation monétaire qui alimenterait
l'inflation qui serait elle même
combattu par une politique de hausse des
taux d'intérêt qui indique handicaperait
le financement entiers de l'économie le
résultat d'une sortie d'un pays de
l'euro est clair
contraction du pays du pied du produit
intérieur brut appauvrissement et
déstabilisation
de toute l'europe est ce que nous
voulons non assurément il faut au
contraire tordre le cou aux idées
économiques aléatoire qui ne sont que
des mirages inepte ce n'est pas parce
que l'union européenne et la zone euro
ne fonctionne pas de façon optimale que
nous devons tout arrêter bien au
contraire
aujourd'hui nous incombe de surmonter
définitivement la crise et de consolider
l'oeuvre entreprise de fait le choc de
la crise a eu un effet remarquable
dans l'urgence et la contrainte parfois
je voulais vous de façon chaotique et
quelque peu tardive le pays de la zone
les pays de la zone euro ont réussi à
améliorer la gouvernance économique
ceci en créant le mécanisme de gestion
de crise pérenne qui manquait
c'est le mécanisme européen de stabilité
en s'accordant également sur des
orientations budgétaires communes c'est
le traité de stabilité et de croissance
la procédure du semestre européen qui
améliore également la supervision
économique et budgétaire tout ceci
forgeant une union bancaire est je le
rappelle c'est en novembre prochain que
la banque centrale européenne eh bien ce
sera officialisé comme organe devant
superviser
précisément les 128 organes bancaires
organisme bancaire de l'ensemble des 28
états membres la conclusion est évidente
même avec ses défauts la zone euro à
résister à la crise en faisant acte de
solidarité
envers les pays en difficulté plus en
difficulté et les marchés financiers ne
se risque plus à considérer son
démantèlement comme possible ceci est le
fruit des engagements des états de la
politique monétaire de la banque
centrale européenne et des efforts
consentis par l'ensemble des citoyens
européens
allons nous relâcher nos efforts
aujourd'hui alors que la situation
économique globale de l'europe est en
voie d'amélioration et qu'elle a des
conséquences politiques qu'il est de
notre responsabilité de traiter ce
serait mon sens gâcher ce que nous avons
construit à la veille d'en récolter
précisément les fruits ce serait renier
une partie de notre histoire ce serait
renier une partie de notre culture
notre objectif pour reprendre les mots
de mario draghi est bien une union plus
parfaite
car pour nous la désaffection à l'égard
de l'europe s'explique largement par les
circonstances économiques actuelles oui
la construction européenne connaît une
période de fragilité
mais la crise nous fait définitivement
comprendre qu'il n'y a pas d'avenir pour
notre pays seuls et isolés
seuls nous ne pourrons pas relever le
défi du chômage
seuls nous ne pourrons pas réussir la
transition énergétique
seuls nous ne pourrons pas gérer la
question de l'immigration
ce dernier sujet intéresse
particulièrement nos concitoyens le
quotidien et les médias nous le
rappellent malheureusement cruellement
presque chaque semaine la libre
circulation des européens est une
réalisation essentiel de l'union à
laquelle ils tiennent ils ont raison
alors comment gérer collectivement
l'arrivée de migrants en situation
illégale
comment accueillir les réfugiés et
traiter les demandes d'asile
comment faire face à des afflux
d'ampleur historique
nous soutenons une plus grande
coopération entre les états membres nous
soutenons la création d'un commissaire
européen à l'immigration et surtout
surtout le renforcement des moyens de
l'agencé frontex en matière économique
si nous voulons résorber le chômage nous
pensons que la convergence et la
cohérence des politiques économiques et
budgétaires est nécessaire
je ne rappellerai pas
qu'on peut appeler entre guillemets le
péché originel qui fut celui de créer
une union monétaire sans
avoir créé une union économique et
budgétaire on savait que la convergence
n'irait pas de soi
c'est effectivement aujourd'hui
malheureusement plus que le cas en effet
c'est en créant des conditions
favorables à l'investissement des
entreprises que l'on trouvera le chemin
d'une croissance durable et créatrice
d'emplois
prendre le risque de bâtir des systèmes
fiscaux et sociaux trop différent c'est
implicitement faire le choix d'une robe
des transferts et des subventions alors
qu'il faudrait collectivement créer de
la croissance et de la richesse
telle est la logique de l'union bancaire
et de la politique monétaire de la
banque centrale européenne que notre
collègue richard yong connais bien et
nous explique régulièrement je dois le
dire c'est dans ce sens que nous devons
poursuivre mais pour nous il y à un
préalable chaque pays doit prendre ses
responsabilités
et faire faire sa part du travail à
savoir réduire ses déficits
réduire son niveau d'endettement et
engager des réformes structurelles
or à ce titre monsieur le ministre la
politique économique actuellement menée
par le gouvernement nous laisse très
sceptique
vous le savez mes collègues du groupe
ump l'ont dit à de nombreuses reprises
au cours de nos débats
espérait le retour à la croissance ne
fait pas une politique
pire encore il fait prendre un risque
collectif à l'europe toute entière
dans cette perspective le débat sur
l'autorité est un faux débat et il faut
arrêter de faire de l'europe un bouc
émissaire comme le dit très justement
notre collègue pierre bernard reymond
dans son rapport nous devons construire
la convergence économique et fiscale en
prenant les bonnes mesures au niveau
national
je sais que ce n'est pas facile mais à
plusieurs reprises dans ce type de débat
je n'ai jamais caché mon intention de
transgresser les cons les particularités
entre partis pour justement que l'on se
retrouve sur des décisions précisément
importante pour l'ensemble de notre pays
de même la transition énergétique
terminer un rapport sur la coopération
énergétique franco allemande qui m'a
beaucoup appris
dans un sou dans un souci tant de
préservation de l'environnement que de
coûts pour nos industries cette
transition énergétique doit être mené
ensemble au niveau européen aucun pays
ne peut la faire seule c'est une des
grandes conclusions que j'en retire le
choix des bouquets énergétiques
nationaux doivent être cohérents et
coordonner nos réseaux doivent être
modernisés en conséquence et
l'indépendance énergétique doit être
appréhendée au niveau européen ce qui se
passe depuis plusieurs semaines et
plusieurs mois en ukraine nous le
rappelle cette indépendance énergétique
ne peut pas se mener en dehors de ce
cadre européen
réinvestissons un des projets d'origine
de la communauté européenne la
communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier et mettons en place
véritablement une véritable union
européenne de l'énergie il y à une vraie
logique agir agir de concert et de vrais
gains à 1 attendre pour nos concitoyens
et bien évidemment pour notre
environnement chers collègues pour
résumer je dirais que le sujet n'est pas
celui d'une europe fédérale
mais de la poursuite d'une construction
selon un modèle original
le choc de la crise et la réponse qui
lui a été collectivement apportés par
l'europe a profondément modifié
l'organisation de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui nous devons franchir une
nouvelle est une nouvelle étape nous
devons nous accorder sur l'étendue et
les modalités de gestion de ce que nous
voulons en commun et trouver un
équilibre entre le communautaire
l'intergouvernemental nous devons
choisir les politiques à traiter
ensemble et ne plus laisser les
administrations européennes réglementée
dans le détail dans de trop nombreux
domaines on le sait on le surveille au
niveau de la commission des affaires
européennes c'est devenu je dirais
presque un peu notre quotidien
j'ai déjà donné plusieurs exemples mais
j'aimerais maintenant aborder la
question d'un point de vue plus
institutionnel nous penser nous pensons
qu'il est très difficile d'envisager une
modification des traités mais qu'il est
tout à fait possible d'avancer dans le
contexte légal actuel pour cela nous
pouvons imaginer une europe à plusieurs
cercles la zone euro doit poursuivre sur
la voie d'une meilleure coordination
économique avec un calendrier
d'harmonisation fiscale
c'est souvent la recommandation que nous
a fait ici jean arthuis nous devons
aussi avancer vers un véritable budget
européen
après les remarques avancé négocié en
fin d'année dernière par notre collègue
alain lamassoure président de la
commission des finances du parlement
parlement européen ce serait un budget
plus important et plus intégrée qui
devra prioritairement financer des
projets communs en matière de recherche
d'infrastructures et de transports nous
devons officialisé leur groupe et mieux
encore
l'identifier par une présidence
permanente pour conclure mes chers
collègues nous sommes conscients que
nombre de nos concitoyens non plus une
approche intuitive de la construction
européenne ils demandent légitimement
une robe plus lisible et plus
démocratique ça a été dit par les
intervenants qui m'ont précédé nous
sommes aussi conscients des faiblesses
du fonctionnement de l'europe et il est
de notre devoir de les corriger il y a
une voix pour l'amélioration mais mais
pas pour l'abandon du projet européen
c'est ce à quoi nous devons nous
employer le choix du futur président de
la commission selon une procédure plus
démocratique en fonction du résultat des
élections au parlement est déjà un
premier pas mais nous devons aller plus
loin dans cette perspective et je
terminerai par l'ap le couple
franco-allemand un rôle pilote
déterminant à jouer
l'europe ne peut se passer du couple
franco allemand non pas comme figure
hégémonique mais comme facteur de
proposition et de dynamisme c'est
pourquoi monsieur le ministre comme j'ai
pu le dire à plusieurs reprises dans
cette émission nous pouvons être
qu'inquiet des divergences économiques
voire politiques qui se creuse de plus
en plus entre nos deux pays car à force
elles vont finir par empêcher la
structuration d'un noyau dur central
européen ou alors la france n'en ferait
pas partie je suis persuadé que surtout
nombre ce n'est pas la solution que nous
souhaitions merci
merci monsieur le sénateur pour le
groupe u10 us et la parole et à madame
catherine morin desailly
si votre collègue veux bien vous laisser
passer vous pourrez intervenir
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les très
prochaines élections européennes aurait
dû être un instant privilégié de notre
vie démocratique pour l'ensemble des
citoyens de l'union or à quelques jours
de ce qui devrait être une respiration
démocratique majeur pour les centaines
de millions d'européens nous sommes
contraints de tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
le taux d'abstention devrait atteindre
des sommets les formations les plus
hostiles à la construction européenne
obtiendrait des résultats bien
supérieurs à leur réel écho public le
soir du 25 mai nous risquons peut-être
de voir plus d'une centaine de députés
anti européen prendre place au parlement
de strasbourg
ces prochaines élections risquent d'être
la manifestation en tout cas la plus
aboutie du malaise qui gangrène les
institutions européennes l'union telle
que nous la connaissons la fille de
notre histoire continentale les drames
du siècle dernier ont fait prendre
conscience à nos aînés de l'urgence et
de l'évidence qu'il y avait à nous unir
l'europe a d'abord été l'europe de la
paix mais elle a été également l'europe
la prospérité de l'innovation et de la
jeunesse on a vite fait de l'oublier la
ceca leurs atomes airbus l'euro erasmus
l'europe enfin c'est celle de la justice
jamais dans l'histoire nous n'avons pu
voir un aussi grand ensemble de
peuplement humain vivre sous l' empire
d'un régime aussi élaboré de protection
des droits de l'homme
quoi qu'on en dise depuis 60 ans
l'europe a agi comme forces de progrès
et de liberté et pourtant l'europe n'a
plus rien d'une évidence pour les
générations actuelles le temps a passé
et nos yeux ne sont plus suffisamment
aguerrie pour mesurer tout ce qu'elle
nous a offert et tout ce qu'elle nous
offre encore aujourd'hui l'europe
apparaît à nos concitoyens désormais
plus comme une source de contraintes
plutôt qu'un atout la crise a joué un
rôle majeur il faut en convenir dans ce
divorce consommé entre un nombre
toujours plus grand de nos concitoyens
et les institutions de l'union l'euro
est devenu bouc émissaire de notre
incapacité à sortir de la crise alors
qui nous a protégés pendant plus d'une
décennie des aléas du monde extérieur
selon la formule de notre collègue jean
arthuis la monnaie unique nous a permis
de jouer les prolongations
elle nous a dispensé de nous réformer
dans le cadre de nos politiques
nationales alors que le monde a
considérablement changé depuis le traité
de maastricht c'est aussi il faut le
reconnaître dans ce retard pris sur la
marche du monde que réside aussi nos
difficultés aujourd'hui
certes l'union cumule plusieurs lacunes
et dysfonctionnements cela était bien
rappeler qu'il empêche de relever les
défis auxquels elle est confrontée est
ce pour autant une raison de tout
abandonner au milieu du chemin donnons
nous au contraire les moyens d'un second
élan le monde actuel est désormais
dominé par des masses humaines politique
commerciale de dimension continentale la
chine les etats-unis et la russie
régente la marche des affaires
internationales face à de tels bloc
l'europe que nous appelons de nos voeux
n'a jamais été autant empreinte de
faiblesse les crise syrienne et irak
ukrainienne font la démonstration de
notre impuissance structurelles face à
la politique d'une russie sûre
d'elle-même et dominatrice même constat
en matière de technologie et
d'innovation
alors que nous disposons de talent nos
politiques nous empêche d'être
concurrentiels face aux géants
américains ou asiatiques de l'internet
le nouveau continent du numérique et je
remercie notre président de l'avoir
rappelé a déjà été conquis et c'est
maintenant l'europe qui est en passe de
devenir une colonie du monde numérique
pour reprendre l'intitulé de mon
précédent rapport sur le sujet nous
devons donc nous battre pour convaincre
de l'évidence il existe une communauté
de destin entre les peuples européens
mais aussi pour en avoir notre maîtrise
seuls nous sommes condamnés à la
marginalisation et n'évoquant ne
serait-ce que la question démographique
pierre bernard-reymond l'a parfaitement
rappelé dans ce siècle qui est le nôtre
nous sommes plus que jamais condamné à
l'uni comment restaurer maintenant le
consensus européen garantir la paix
ramener la prospérité et faire enfin
accoucher l'europe de son véritable
potentiel nous avons évidemment besoin
de plus d'europe mais pas n'importe
laquelle pour les sénateurs de notre
groupe il n'y a pas deux manières de
penser l'europe deux visions distinctes
nous sommes clairs sur l'essentiel c'est
le manque d'harmonisation entre les pays
européens l'absence de politique
intégrée ambitieuse pour protéger et
promouvoir nos intérêts communs
économiques sociaux et culturels
une harmonisation pour une nouvelle
unité qui permettra alors d'accoucher de
partenariat conditionnant une partie de
l'avenir de l'union je pense bien
évidemment à l'afrique les sénateurs de
notre groupe ne cesse d'appeler à la
relance des relations européennes avec
les pays africains à travers un
partenariat rénové car une chose est
sûre la frite forte de son potentiel
géants de demain ne nous en a nous
attendra pas ou alors d'autres s'en
occuperont nous appelons ainsi un
approfondissement
désormais nécessaire pour plus d'emplois
plus de protection plus de démocratie à
vrai dire le chantier le plus urgent de
l'europe et de combler le fossé
démocratique il éloigne depuis trop
longtemps de ses citoyens nous avons
besoin d'institutions responsable et
incarner devant les citoyens de
politique européenne évalue est porté à
la connaissance de tous est
sanctionnable dans les urnes la
démocratie doit être l'aiguillon de la
construction européenne de demain sans
une architecture institutionnelle
robuste solide et démocratique l'europe
telle que nous la connaissons finira par
s'écrouler sous son propre poids l'euro
doit ainsi être par ailleurs achevé et
marcher sur ses deux jambes nous avons
donc besoin d'un gouvernement économique
intégrée qui manie à la fois la
politique budgétaire et fiscale en lien
avec la bce ce gouvernement doit être
responsable devant les citoyens de
l'union c'est pourquoi le parlement
européen doit devenir une véritable
chambre forte de toutes les compétences
dévolues à une grande assemblée
parlementaire l'assemblée
interparlementaire
constitué par l'article 13 du tsc v
pourrait constituer l'embryon d'une
seconde chambre qui vous présenterez
aussi les citoyens à travers le prisme
des états et dans le cadre strict de la
zone euro
cet édifice sera le noyau du nouveau
fédéralisme européen que les sénateurs
centristes appellent de leurs voeux ce
serait là le préalable à tout
renforcement de la pac à toute politique
environnementale ambitieuse à notre
politique de défense à la prise en
compte des enjeux de l'europe maritime à
la gestion des flux migratoires
en tout état de cause cette refonte
démocratique de nos institutions est la
condition nécessaire à la réussite des
politiques publiques européennes et cela
est particulièrement vrai pour
l'ensemble des secteurs stratégiques qui
concerne les politiques à venir à ce
titre le travail mené par notre mission
commune d'information relative à la
gouvernance de l'internet est sur le
point de collaborer ce diagnostic
général je parle bien sûr sur le
contrôle de mes collègues andré gattolin
et les gens visés ici présents après
avoir auditionné plus de 50 acteurs de
l'internet mondial et européen que ce
soit à bruxelles en allemagne ou aux
états unis il apparaît que l'europe
bénéficié en la matière d'une
opportunité historique la gouvernance de
l'internet souffre de la perte du
magistère moral
exercé naguère par les états unis après
laffaire snowdown la tentation est
grande désormais pour les nations de
l'internet démocratique ne se replier
sur elle-même dans un tel contexte
l'europe à l'occasion de s'affirmer
comme le tiers de confiance en mesure
d'infléchir la gouvernance internet dans
un sens dans un sens conforme à nos
valeurs de respect de la vie privée et
de garantie de la liberté de chacun
l'europe en a l'opportunité mais en at
elle les moyens
nos institutions nous permettait dans
l'état de prendre des décisions fermes
et rapides nos institutions sont elles
en mesure de densifier le tissu
industriel de l'internet européen en
l'état actuel des choses je ne le crois
pas et c'est bien dommage car c'est un
enjeu qui concerne déjà tous les
secteurs de l'activité humaine et
personnellement tous les citoyens de
l'union notre mission commune
d'information fera donc des propositions
en ce sens dans les semaines à venir
afin de joindre le geste à la parole et
en vue de m et le fossé démocratique qui
éloigne les citoyens de l'union je ne
ferai que formulé un voeu nous avons des
citoyens prêts au débat nous disposons
des moyens techniques de mener une vaste
concernant concertation continental
aussi pourquoi ne pas faire de la france
le fer de lance une grande consultation
européenne sur l'europe que nos
concitoyens souhaiterez voilà que nous
donnerait enfin la pleine mesure de ce à
quoi l'europe des 50 prochaines années
devrait ressembler pour conclure je
rappellerai en 1916 et guillaume
apollinaire pour être français d'origine
polonaise italienne écrivait il est
grand temps de rallumer les étoiles
aujourd'hui nous sommes à nouveau dans
une situation engagé européens devons
nous mobiliser pour dire l'europe que
nous voulons afin de rallumer les
étoiles européennes à cet égard je
remercie notre président si mon futur
d'avoir pris l'initiative de ce débat
merci chers collègues pour le groupe
sears et la parole et hamish à madame
michelle demessine
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
à quelques jours de l'élection des
représentants parlement européen ce
débat évidemment me semble plus
qu'essentiel bien que depuis quelques
temps nous assistons un regain d'intérêt
dans l'ensemble les enjeux de ce scrutin
sont passés sous silence
malheureusement une grande majorité des
français se désintéressent totalement de
cette élection et la plupart de ceux qui
y participent s'interroge
sur la portée même de leur vote
pourtant le 25 mai prochain tous les
citoyens européens ont le pouvoir de
donner le sens qu'ils veulent à l'europe
choisir quel développement est le plus
approprié pour l'intérêt des peuples
après tout dépend évidemment de la
nature de l'ambition que l'on porte sur
les véritables perspectives pour
l'europe l'europe ne pourra dépasser les
obstacles actuels sans une adhésion des
peuples à un projet ambitieux
l'europe ne pourra continuer sa
construction si elle ne prend pas acte
du besoin démocratique et de
transparence grandissant dans nos
sociétés
l'enjeu majeur des années à venir est
donc bien de remettre au centre des
préoccupations européennes citoyens les
politiques menées par l'union européenne
ces dernières décennies sont pourtant
loin de favoriser le développement des
coopérations utile entre les 28 pays qui
composent l'union c'est au contraire est
de plus en plus la mise en concurrence
des papes et des territoires qui est
organisée
petit à petit on le voit ce phénomène
est en train de tuer l'europe car cette
concurrence exacerbée mais les peuples
sous tension et concentre toutes sortes
de sentiments des plus nauséabond
pourtant l'idée originelle de la
création de l'union européenne était la
création d'une zone de paix certes pour
favoriser les échanges marchands et le
développement économique
mais la nécessité d'une paix durable et
est un élément fondamental
or aujourd'hui nous constatons une
nouvelle fois après la guerre des
balkans que cette paix n'est pas
forcément acquise et qu'elle est même
engagé à nouveau aux portes de l'union
nous ne pouvons ignorer la crise
dramatique que traverse l'ukraine cette
situation doit nous inquiéter et nous
faire réagir dans ce drame l'union
européenne devrait soutenir bien
davantage l'organisation d'élections
dans un climat apaisé le peuple
ukrainien doit pouvoir décider s'il
souhaite ou non préserver l'unité
l'unité d'un territoire et l'intégrité
de ses frontières c'est une des
ambitions que doit justement soutenir
une union européenne porteuse de paix
contrairement à l'actuelle incapacité
chronique de l'union européenne a joué
un rôle positif dans les conflits du
monde et particulièrement dans ceux des
pays voisins de plus si nous voulons que
l'europe prenne un nouveau tournant
qu'elle se développe sur les bases d'une
véritable coopération entre les nations
dans l'intérêt des peuples du monde et
peuples d'europe et de ceux du monde
entier il est aussi nécessaire
d'informer les citoyens des véritables
enjeux prenons l'exemple du projet
d'accord transatlantique
négocié en secret et donc la plus grande
majorité des français ignorent même
l'existence et la portée des enjeux
alors qu'il s'agit de la coupe et copie
conforme du projet d' accord
multilatéral sur l'investissement
négocier lui dans le plus grand secret
entre 95 et 97
rejeté in extremis grâce à la percée des
informations par la société civile et à
la pression populaire qui s'en est suivi
ce projet d'accord transatlantique est
une véritable menace pour les droits
sociaux et l'emploi l'environnement
l'agriculture les droits civiques et la
vie privée la santé la régulation
financière et la démocratie et les
services publics mais qui le sait nous
ne pouvons laisser perdurer ces
négociations dans la plus grande opacité
et honnêtement nous ne pouvons compter
sur le gouvernement puisque le président
de la république en personne souhaite
qu'on accélère les négociations pour
éviter les contestations à ce sujet je
dois avouer que le comportement des
députés socialistes lors de l'examen en
commission de la proposition de
résolution européenne déposée par les
députés du front de gauche demandant
l'arrêt des négociations sur le projet
d'accord de libre-échange entre l'union
européenne les états unis d'amérique ne
va pas pour nous rassurer sur leur
volonté d'assurer une plus grande
transparence devant de tels enjeux
d'avenir car les députés socialistes
malheureusement ont vidé cette
proposition de résolution de sa
substance validant ainsi la poursuite
des négociations sur un grand marché
transatlantique
alors même que beaucoup de milieux très
divers
venant de beaucoup de milieux très
divers des alertes sont ans selon sont
lancés sur le danger et les effets
néfastes pour notre économie d'un tel
chambardement économique mondiale autre
élément indispensable pour une
construction européenne cohérente le
parlement européen bien que ces
compétences ont été renforcées il ne
paraît pas avoir les moyens ou la
volonté d' infléchir les décisions d'un
conseil ou d'une commission tout
puissant jamais le fossé entre les
institutions européennes et citoyens été
aussi grand c'est même devenu un gouffre
aujourd'hui malgré ces dernières
évolutions l'équilibré entre les
différents pouvoirs au sein de l'union
européenne est loin d'être atteint
c'est pourquoi la position et le rôle du
parlement européen paraissent donc un
axe essentiel pour la construction de
l'europe il est nécessaire de lui donner
les moyens de décider réellement des
politiques à conduire au sein de l'union
européenne
autre question sur laquelle l'europe ne
pourra faire l'impasse c'est celle de la
relance d'une politique industrielle
cohérente
l'actualité avec la proposition de
rachat d'une partie de l'activité
d'alstom par general electric
l'offre du groupe pharmaceutique
américain psy faire peas air sur asra
n'est qu'en grande bretagne ou encore la
façon dont la commission européenne mène
son enquête en allemagne sur la fusion
des deux opérateurs téléphoniques
suscite
nombre d'interrogations même le lobby
des très grandes entreprises européennes
reproche à la commission de ne pas être
assez protectrices des intérêts
stratégiques de l'union de ne pas être
assez analytique sur les besoins
d'investissement à long terme et de ne
pas préserver les capacités de recherche
ces dernières années les critiques à
l'encontre de bruxelles et de sa
politique de concurrence se sont
amplifiées la commission ne peut
continuer sur cette voie il est
indéniable que si l'europe veut exister
et jouer un rôle au plan international
elle doit impérativement favoriser une
politique industrielle conséquence en
caux réparation avec l'ensemble des pays
il suffit de regarder la situation de la
sncm pour voir que cette vision de la
concurrence libre et non faussée ne peut
que couler l'industrie européenne
l'union européenne a condamné la
compagnie maritime a remboursé 440
millions d'euros au titre du
remboursement de subventions perçues on
lui met une épée de damoclès alors même
que la sncm propose un plan industriel
consistant qui a des impacts forts pour
l'emploi direct et indirect avec
notamment les chantiers navals
tout cela on le voit s'inscrit dans la
logique de la commission de
libéralisation des transports qui visent
in fine et abaisser les règles du droit
social nous ne pouvons approuver une
telle vision de l'europe les salariés
doivent pouvoir s'impliquer pleinement
dans les choix stratégiques de
développement de l'entreprise des
propositions peuvent aller dans ce sens
notamment il serait possible dans le
cadre des comités d'entreprise européens
de donner aux salariés des droits sur
les choix stratégiques
investissements localisation montant des
dividendes ou encore d'interdire
l'action des fonds financier prédateur
respectives hâtif les perspectives de la
construction européenne sont un sujet si
vaste qu'il y aura encore nombre de
points à aborder mais pour conclure et
dans le temps qui m'est donnée je dirais
qu enfin qu afin que les citoyens se
sentent réellement appliquée dans le
processus de construction répétable
européenne il me semble indispensable de
rendre systématique la consultation des
peuples sont les traités essentiel les
sénateurs du groupe crc pense également
qu'il est urgent d'avancer sur
l'harmonisation fiscale et sociale il
est nécessaire de construire une autre
europe celle qui entend les peuples et
agit pour le programme merci de votre
attention
dans la suite du débat la parole est un
monsieur jean pierre chevènement orateur
du groupe rdse
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
alors que vous venez de prendre vos
fonctions mais fait le ministre ce dont
nous nous réjouissons
permettez moi d'effectuer un bref rappel
quand le gouvernement le 19 octobre 2012
a demandé au parlement de ratifier le
traité dit et à ce sujet sur la
stabilité la coordination la gouvernance
il nous a incités à le contextualiser à
voir ce qu'il y avait autour et après un
derrière l' annexe sur la croissance
après la taxe sur les transactions
financières et puis la régulation
bancaire
j'ai rappelé en défendant une exception
de recevabilité dire sa vérité que je
vais déposer avec mon collègue pierre
yves collombat
que ce traité posé le principe d'un
retour et l'équipe budgétaire sous le
contrôle de la commission européenne
selon un calendrier fixé par elles et
qu'il était facile de prévoir qui nous
entraînerait dans une spirale
récessionniste dont nous ne sortirions
que par une crise politique et sociale
de grande ampleur
je n'ai pas l'habitude de me citer mais
voilà je le peux m'empêcher de dire
revenir c'était il ya moins de deux ans
mais femis nous y sommes nous y sommes
la mise en oeuvre de plans d'austérité
budgétaire simultanée dans la plupart
des pays d'europe les a plongés dans une
stagnation économique de longue durée au
premier trimestre 2014
la croissance est nulle en france
négative en italie à chypre en grèce -
1,1 pour cent au portugal -1 07 aux
pays-bas mois 1,4 en finlande - 04 seule
l'allemagne avec une croissance de 0,8
permet à la zone euro d'afficher une
croissance globale de 0,2 sur l'ensemble
de l'année la croissance prévue est de
1% c'est à dire une croissance
qui sera deux fois et demie à cette fois
inférieur un sel qu'on prévoit dans les
autres régions du monde voilà c'est la
réalité de l'europe de nous avons par p
alors madame morin desailly qui n'est
plus là mais je veux quand même
l'évoquer a cité un polymère
s'agissait de rallumer les étoiles et
heureux cette inspiration était présente
dans le rapport de monsieur pierre
bernard émond mais il me semble que
j'aurais réhabiliter un pharmacien
lorrain
dont le nom était le docteur coué qui a
une grande
vogue dans les années 20 parce que il
guérissait les gens en le faisant
répéter tous les jours demain sera
meilleur qu'aujourd'hui mais n'est ce
pas le light motif que en dehors du
propos de madame de messine j'ai entendu
ce soir sur ses bancs demain sera
meilleur qu'aujourd'hui mais nous
regardons la croissance en berne un pnb
de la zone euro qui n'a pas retrouvé ou
à peine pour ce qui concerne la france
le niveau de 2008 en 2013 cinq ans après
d'où un déplacement que l'opinion
commence à percevoir la chute de
l'investissement générale dans toute
l'europe
le chômage qui atteint dans les pays de
l'europe du sud des niveaux sans
précédent en grèce en espagne 26 % au
portugal 18 en italie 13 en france 11 la
déflation qui menace avec eux une hausse
de prix de 0 7% elle renchérit le crédit
et plombe à la fois la consommation et
l'investissement
le seul point positif noté par monsieur
bizet c'est la balance commerciale
excédentaire de la zone euro mais vous
le savez très bien cela tient
essentiellement à quasiment uniquement à
l'excédent commercial allemand perd que
la réalité c'est pour nous un déficit de
plus de 60 milliards
alors l'allemagne bénéficié du cours de
l'euro du fait de la spécialisation haut
de gamme de son économie al'inverse
cette parité de l'euro pénalise les
autres pays moins bien placé dans la
division du travail notamment la france
qui ne peuvent s'ajuster qu en
comprimant leurs salaires et leurs
investissements ou en acceptant un
déficit commercial qui est également
très importante 3.2 plein b
cet écart de compétitivité structurel au
sein de la zone euro révèle je le répète
pour la énième fois révèle le défaut de
conception de la monnaie unique est
votre conception qui remonte à 1992
quand même un peu avant
jaune unique évidemment monnaie unique
pardon évidemment inadaptée à une zone
économique hétérogènes la seule issue
économique à long terme c'est la mezzo
giorni nation c'est la régression
d'ensemble des pays d'europe du sud est
le seul moyen d'éviter cette issue
serait la transformation de l'euro de
monnaie unique en monnaie commune avec
des subdivisions nationale qui seraient
des subdivisions de l'euro comme entre
1999 et 2002 quand il y avait une
monnaie bancaire une monnaie scripturale
avec une seule différence c'est qu'il y
aurait des possibilités d'ajustement
périodique fondée sur des critères
objectifs comme par exemple la
productivité ou le déficit de la balance
commerciale
on ferait ainsi l'économie de
dévaluation interne si douloureuses
qu'elles ne manqueront pas de se
traduire dimanche prochain dans le
résultat des prochaines élections
européennes 1 l'arrêt l'abstention
massive qu'on peut prévoir sans risque
de se tromper sera la réponse une
nouvelle fois apporté au déni de
démocratie qu'a constitué le traité de
lisbonne 2 décembre 2007 après le non
massif
55% des français au projet de
constitution européenne le 29 mai 2005
cette solution politique du problème
posé par l'euro est une idée qui
commence déjà à faire son chemin de
l'autre côté du rhin en allemagne et
attendez vous en effet un score
intéressant un deux genres qui développe
cette idée que au fond l'allemagne ne
peut pas
assurer à long terme la survie de la
zone euro je pense en effet que cette
vue et et jusque
nous sommes aujourd'hui le sud mise dans
un cercle vicieux la stagnation
économique pèse sur les rentrées
fiscales
empêche la réduction des déficits fait
s'envoler le niveau de la dette et cela
d'autant plus que le pnb besson mêmes
s'effondrant dans des pays comme
l'espagne ou la grèce vient
naturellement le niveau de l'endettement
s'élève j'ai des statistiques il est un
peu juin 2013 mais c'est 94 pour
l'espagne 94 % pour l'espagne 133 pour
l'italie 126 pour l'irlande 131 pour le
portugal cent soixante dix pour la grèce
pour celle ci et pour l'irlande
peut-être pour chypre une
restructuration de la dette est
inévitable
alors on sait bobby
de ce que les pays fortement endettés de
la zone euro peuvent désormais se
refinancer à long terme à des taux moins
élevés de l'ordre de 3 ou 4% par an mais
c'est oublier que la banque centrale
européenne a ouvert aux banques
italiennes espagnoles notamment des
prêts colossaux dit elle terreau qui
leur permettent des placements très
avantageux dans la dette souveraine de
leur payer cette injection de liquidités
ne l'ayant pas suffisante pour animer le
crédit aux entreprises et sortir la zone
euro du marasme
notre gouvernement et il a raison
demandent à la banque centrale
européenne d'agir pour faire baisser le
cours de l'euro surévalué pour
l'économie française mais comme je le
rappelais à l'instant il ne l'est pas
pour l'allemagne qui a beau jeu
d'évoquer à l'appui d'une interprétation
à mon avis excessivement stricts du
traité de maëstricht l'article 88 de ces
lois fondamentales qui prohibe tout prêt
de la banque centrale à l'état empêchant
ainsi ce que les anglo-saxons appellent
le quantitative easing ce que font les
états unis la grande bretagne du japon
ne vont pas nous permettre depuis 12 ans
ont signé le traité de maëstricht les
pratiques que la loi de fondamentale
allemande prohibe et la cour côté de
castres où veillent au respect de la
règle ne sont par là même interdite qui
en 1992 on avait avisé et les citoyens
français et les autres européens alors
une patiente recherches diligentées par
la fondation res publica
a fait apparaître quand même que le
premier président de la bce monsieur
duizendstraal avait retenu la
possibilité évoquée par les mises des
finances réunis en décembre 1997 de
formuler des orientations générales en
matière de changes uniquement dans des
circonstances exceptionnelles par
exemple je le cite lorsque le taux de
change de l'euro subit des divergences
manifestes et persistante je tiens ces
textes à votre disposition monsieur le
ministre et je vous pose la question
n'est ce pas le cas aujourd'hui le cours
de l'euro est supérieur de 15 à 20% à
son cours de lancement il faudrait
proposer d'introduire des montants
compensatoires monétaire auld au delà de
certains déséquilibres externes trois
années d'excédents au-delà de 6% comme
prévu par l'union elle-même ou quatre
points de pnb l'excédent à deux points
de déficit comme proposé par les états
unis au g20 de séoul sans doute
faudrait-il tester la possibilité de
réunir une majorité au conseil des
gouverneurs de la bce éventuellement
sans l'allemagne pour introduire des
mesures correctrices à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne en matière de taux
d'intérêt ou le taux de change si une
telle perspective s'avérer des
vieillissements impossible eh bien il
faudrait mettre à l'étude un nouveau
traité introduit sans la monnaie commune
après une place de transition à laquelle
peut nous conduire rapidement
l'instabilité non corrigée du système
financier international
parce que je veux on conclure là dessus
il faut cesser monsieur le ministre de
se raconter des histoires sur une crise
de l'euro enfin surmonté ou bien sûr
lyon bancaire ou encore sur la taxe sur
les transactions financières
internationales à la bastille étroite
qu'elle ne rapportera que 5 milliard
d'euros par an réformes cosmétiques pour
l'union bancaire c'est le modèle
chypriote qui a été retenu par monsieur
driss el bleues c'est à dire la mise à
contribution en cas de faillite bancaire
des créanciers des déposants au delà du
montant garanti c'était vers cent mille
euros et cela au au mépris des
engagements pris je conclu monsieur le
président le meilleur moyen de
déclencher des réactions systémique en
cas de crise mais surgit seul blom la
trouver c le système qu'il nous a
proposé et qui a semble t'il été
entérinée vous savez qu'une crise n'est
malheureusement pas à exclure pour un
tas de raisons sur lesquelles je passe
ce monde est dangereux une ministre
gardons nous de l'aborder avec des idées
trop simple donnons leur place à la
raison je pense à la crise ukrainienne
qui requiert une solution politique
dégagé des préjugés russophobe et
donnons aussi là ça donne aussi sa place
à la créativité je pense en particulier
à politique monétaire un nouveau mandat
va être donné à la commission c'est la
dernière occasion à saisir monsieur mist
pour faire que d'une manière concertée
où il en est les messieurs qui se
présente je pense mme à l'horizon j'ai
terminé monsieur le président je vous
rassure
merci merci
dans la suite du débat la parole est à
monsieur richard yung orateur du groupe
socialiste
le président mais ces milices mes chers
collègues je voudrais concentrer mon
propos dans ce débat sur l'avenir de
l'union monétaire car à l'instar de
notre rapporteur de notre collègue
pierre bernard émond je pense que la
zone euro contrairement à monsieur
chevénement et le cadre adapté pour
affirmer une véritable ambition
européennes la monnaie unique constitue
le symbole le plus fort du projet
européen avec la paix c'est donc
logiquement autour d'elle que se
développe aujourd'hui un ensemble plus
intégré plus solidaire et plus
démocratique je rappelle deux ou trois
points qui me semblent parmi les plus
importants la crise a permis à la zone
euro de franchir une étape décisive en
matière d'intégration contrairement à
toutes les annonces pessimistes et euros
au style qui ont été faites à ce moment
là les institutions ont mené à bien des
réformes qui était inimaginable il ya
encore quelques années et la zone euro
contrairement à toutes ces attentes n'a
pas implosé
une plus grande différenciation
institutionnels à l'intérieur de la zone
euro c'est fait s'est constitué je vous
rappelle qu'à été constitués
l'eurogroupe qui a donné une base
juridique et des instruments juridiques
pour les pays de la zone euro le sommet
de la zone euro a été mis en place et
c'est un point important
qui a donné lieu ensuite au traité sur
la stabilité la coordination et la
gouvernance au sein de l'union et on a
donc un embryon un embryon faible certes
mais un embryon quand même de
gouvernance européenne nous avons aussi
profiter de cette crise pour des
avancées majeures en matière de
prévention et de gestion des crises
je rappelle le l'union bancaire mais ce
jeu vainement considéré que c'était peu
de choses moi je considère que c'est une
avancée formidable
nous avons un régulateur
unique la banque centrale européenne
nous avons un mécanisme de jugement des
crises bancaires et nous mettons en
place un système de paiement pour faire
face aux différences bancaire qui fait
que ça sera plus le contribuable qui
payera les crises bancaires
moi je trouve que c'est un progrès nous
l'avons fait au niveau français nous le
faisons au niveau européen
c'est donc à mon avis une avancée
décisive
je ne partage pas votre votre point de
vue là dessus
je rappelle que l'union bancaire
va mettre du temps malheureusement à se
faire certains d'entre nous aurait voulu
que ça se fasse rapidement mais il ya un
délai de l'ordre de 10 ans pour que
toute cette mécanique se met en place il
ya donc à mettre en place en attendant
ce qu'on appelle le filet de sécurité
à cette fin nous sommes un certain
nombre à proposer que le fonds unique de
résolution c'est-à-dire ce fonds qui
perd qui ferait face aux défaillances
bancaires soit adossée au moins pendant
cette période là au mécanisme européen
de stabilité mais pour cela il faut
convaincre la chancelière il faut
convaincre la chancelière allemande
madame merkel qui elle refuse toute
modification et tout changement dans le
mécanisme européen de stabilité je crois
que c'est un message que nous devons
envoyer à notre gouvernement et à notre
président
je rappelle que la banque centrale
européenne a joué un rôle décisif bien
qu'elle ne soit pas à proprement parler
une institution de la zone euro mais une
institution de l'union européenne la
banque centrale a orienté l'essentiel de
ses activités vers la saône vers la zone
euro
est loin d' appliquer comme ç'avait été
le cas une lecture
étroite du mandat qui lui a été donné et
que et que défendent
que défend la banque centrale allemande
que défend le gouvernement allemand elle
a au contraire pris des initiatives
fortes qui ont permis de faire face à la
crise je rappelle les interventions sur
le marché secondaire et leur financement
dans des proportions extrêmement large
500 milliards des banques commerciales
elle a donc réduit les tensions sur la
dette souveraine sur la dette des états
alors il nous reste encore évidemment
beaucoup de travail devant nous il faut
en particulier remédier aux défauts
structurels de construction qui ont déjà
été évoqués
je pense qu'il faut d'abord proposé
défendre cette idée qui fait son chemin
de fer de la zone euro une véritable
union politique
ça peut se faire sous différentes formes
création d'un président permanent de
l'eurogroupe une soeur de ministres des
finances de la zone euro qui auraient
des pouvoirs
décisionnels autonome et qui pourrait
aussi impulser des initiatives en
matière fiscale et sociale
je pense qu'il faut aussi veiller au
renforcement de ce qu'on appelle le
contrôle démocratique de la zone euro
c'est un problème délicat enfin quand
même difficile vous verrez que en
première page du monde aujourd'hui
thomas picketty l'économiste dis
clairement il faut un parlement de la
zone euro et il développe ensuite cette
idée là il le fait en disant qu'il faut
créer au fond une seconde chambre qui
serait une chambre d etat le bundesrat
si vous voulez avec des représentants
des parlements nationaux comme c'est le
cas au bundesrat qui siège au niveau au
niveau européen c'est une des
possibilités en tout cas
moi je retire de d'un certain nombre de
réunions nous avons eu dans le cas de ce
qu'on appelle l'article 13 du tsg c'est
à dire l'idée qui a qu'il faut un
contrôle des parlements nationaux sur
les mesures de politiques monétaires
et financières aurel je tire l'idée que
nous n'arriverons pas dans cette voie là
parce que nous avons l'opposition des
députés européens qui disent mais c'est
nous qui sommes légitimes dans ce
domaine là qu'est ce que vous venez
faire vous élus nationaux et nous avons
l'opposition du gouvernement
de la plupart des partis allemands que
ce soit là c'est deus est sourd ou que
ce soit le spd alors ça fait beaucoup
quand même ça fait beaucoup pour avancer
donc il faudra il faut trouver une
tactique différente en la matière mais
c'est clair que nous devons absolument
avancer sur ce point aujourd'hui le
parlement national nous semblait
nationale mais nous nous sommes démunis
par rapport à l'ensemble de ces débats
et par alan à par rapport à l'ensemble
de ces deux cd 6 voilà je pense que
c'est c'est l'essentiel je pense que
nous devons ça a été dit avancer dans la
voie de l'union budgétaire
nous pourrions
reprendre une idée qui a été évoquée ici
qui est la mutualisation partielle des
dépenses d'indemnisation du chômage
c'est une idée que notre collègue
dominique bailly a déjà défendu qui a
été reprise ici que moi je trouve bonne
il aura peut-être l'occasion de leur
propre je ne dis rien sur la taxe sur
les transactions financières elle avance
mais clopin clopant voilà on peut pas on
va pas dire on va pas dire autre et
enfin je pense comme ça a été dit
excellemment par monsieur raymond que
nous devons
envisager imaginer la possibilité pour
l'europe de se financer en émettant des
euro-obligations qui seraient d'ailleurs
pas un endettement puisqu'elle serait
sur le marché à seraient remboursés
voilà
voilà quelques années quelques idées
pour avancer sur ce sujet j'en profite
pour rendre hommage à notre collègue il
nous a donné l'occasion d'un bon débat
européen
dans la suite du débat la parole est à
madame colette mélot orateur du groupe
ump
ce sera
tous
il
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires européennes
monsieur le rapporteur de la commission
tout a commencé le 9 mai 1950 par la
déclarer la déclaration de robert
schuman
ainsi les pères fondateurs de la
construction européenne ont permis de
réconcilier les européens et d'instaurer
la paix et la prospérité dans des pays
qui se déchiraient depuis plus d'un
siècle
ce fut d'abord la création de la
communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier en 1952 puis la communauté
économique européenne et la communauté
européenne de l'énergie atomique en 1957
le 22 janvier 1963
le général de gaulle et le chancelier
adenauer signèrent le traité de l'élysée
ce traité posera la première pierre
d'une coopération entre les deux pays et
lancera ainsi le couple franco-allemand
qui demeure le moteur de la construction
européenne dans les années soixante dix
valéry giscard d'estaing et helmut
schmidt faire avancer la coopération sur
de nombreuses questions politiques clés
les deux hommes d'état aujourd'hui
encore continue à poser un regard lucide
sur la construction européenne et n'ont
pas perdu leurs convictions profondes
nous devons garder en mémoire ces actes
fondateurs et affirmé que l'europe est
une chance pour nous et nos enfants
aujourd'hui l'union européenne apporte
aux peuples qui la composent beaucoup
davantage et peu d'inconvénients
même s'il ne faut pas faire preuve de
robes et attitudes car il ya beaucoup de
faiblesses mais comment peut-on imaginer
revenir en arrière alors que des grands
blocs s'affirme dans le monde la chine
l'inde et le brésil se hisse au rang des
grandes puissances les états unis
d'amérique ne sont plus tout à fait les
maîtres du monde aujourd'hui l'union
européenne représente 500 millions de
citoyens
aujourd'hui la zone euro constitué par
18 pays est sans doute la première
puissance du monde en pib cumulé notre
monnaie est recherchée face au dollar
cela lui est même reproché alors que
l'euro est un acquis fondamental de
l'europe c'est un facteur de stabilité
certains détracteurs affirment que
l'euro fort est un frein aux
exportations françaises
les résultats de la balance commerciale
de l'allemagne apporte un contre exemple
avec la monnaie unique des comparaisons
peuvent être aisément établi cependant
il est vrai que tous les pays européens
ne peuvent pas ou ne veulent pas faire
partie de la zone euro c'est une réalité
qu'il faut admettre et l'europe doit
pouvoir fonctionner avec une géométrie
variable un noyau dur avec une évolution
de politiques plus intégrée et un espace
européen de libre échange avec des
politiques renforcer dans certains
domaines ainsi il est difficile
d'envisager l'union européenne sans le
royaume uni c'est un grand pays européen
et ses gouvernants savent eux bien
d'ailleurs que l'union européenne est
déterminante pour l'avenir pourtant ils
ne veulent pas se soumettre aux règles
de la zone euro il faut donc trouver un
autre cadre qui peut être celui d'un
espace de libre échange avec certaines
coopération pour faire évoluer l'union
européenne la france a un rôle
déterminant à jouer
mario monti qui a été reçue récemment à
l'académie des sciences morales et
politiques a donné une leçon d'europe et
a fait un appel à la france il a déclaré
il serait bon que la france redevienne
la force de proposition et d'impulsion
qu'elle a su être par le passé
un peu plus loin il faut réfuter
catégoriquement toute idée d'une
alliance des pays du sud contre
l'allemagne
l'enjeu est plutôt que la france
redevienne la france c'est à dire
qu'elle joue pleinement son rôle de pont
avec l'allemagne ce qui suppose
toutefois qu'elle améliore ses
performances a dit l'ancien premier
ministre de l'italie ancien commissaire
européen et économiste reconnu
l'europe ne se développera et ne se
consolidera qu'à cette condition
c'est l'histoire de nos deux nations la
france et l'allemagne qui a été à
l'origine de l'europe et nous deux pays
représentent la moitié de l'économie
européenne les principaux griefs qui
sont fait à l'europe sont la conséquence
d'une méconnaissance des atouts l'europe
c'est du un profond déficit de
communication
nous devons aussi sortir des égoïsmes
nationaux nous devons en finir avec les
arguments qui font de l'europe un bouc
émissaire ces arguments conduisent les
peuples au populisme dans une période de
fragilité économique et monétaire il est
logique de rechercher la protection de
l'état souverain mais n'est ce pas en
repli est aussi un danger n'oublions pas
que les populismes dans l'histoire ont
conduit à la guerre de plus les
eurosceptiques ne propose rien nous
entendons souvent aussi un regret
concernant l'élargissement de l'europe
aux pays de l'est et pourtant cet
élargissement est indispensable à
l'évolution de la démocratie dans la
partie orientale de notre continent nous
pouvons nous demander si la situation
que nous déplorons and ukraine ne se
serait pas produite dans les pays baltes
ou en europe centrale si ces pays
n'avaient pas rejoint l'europe dix ans
après leur adhésion les huit pays
d'europe centrale et orientale se
félicitent de leur entrée dans l'union
européenne
l'ouverture au grand marché a dopé
l'activité et favoriser les exportations
et l'investissement à l'étranger
l'investissement pardon étrangers de
l'estonie à la slovénie l'effet a été
positif le même que dans les années 80
en irlande en espagne ou au portugal
avec des taux de croissance de 6 à 10%
la pologne a su tirer profit des aides
de bruxelles si nous comparons les deux
pays voisins que sont la pologne et
l'ukraine le résultat est impressionnant
les deux pays sont sortis de la période
soviétique avec un revenu moyen à peu
près égales la pologne s'est débarrassé
de son carcan en privatisant et en
déréglementant c'est maintenant une
démocratie reconnue le chômage y est
encore plus fort qu'ailleurs en europe
et le revenu encore inférieur mais les
polonais en haut niveau de vie quatre
fois supérieur à celui des ukrainiens
sur les dix entre en 2004 six ont déjà
basculé dans l'euro électoralement même
s'il est parti pour liste ont vu le jour
la contestation de l'europe contre bien
des idées reçues ne fait plus recette de
ce côté là de vieux continent et cela
même si certains pays ont dû connaître
une récession et des difficultés ces
dernières années dans son rapport
d'information l'union européenne du
crépuscule nouvel élan
notre excellent collègue pierre bernard
reymond a décrit les différentes étapes
de la construction européenne fait une
analyse de grande qualité de la
situation de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui et a formulé 24 propositions
pour contribuer à un nouvel élan c'est
une bonne source de réflexion et ce
rapport doit faire date dans nos travaux
il est indispensable de mieux
communiquer sur l'europe est de
sensibiliser les citoyens khalid et de
civilisation européenne c'est un point
essentiel soulevées par le rapporteur à
mon sens il faut aussi relancer des
coopérations d'avenir dans le domaine de
la recherche et de l'éducation
le programme erasmus a permis à
plusieurs millions d'étudiants de
découvrir l'europe c'est une très grande
réussite
le programme erasmus plus devrait
concerner en cours encore plus
d'étudiants pour l'avenir c'est un
exemple emblématique
cependant des harmonisations sont
nécessaires au niveau fiscal et social
et des réformes économiques
financières sociales doivent surtout
s'opérer au niveau de la zone euro
c'est-à-dire du noyau dur pour tout cela
le moteur franco allemand doit jouer un
rôle essentiel dans l'espace européen
comprenant aussi le deuxième cercle
nous pourrions envisager une politique
de la défense elle a cruellement manqué
dans les récents conflits et s'avère
indispensable pour l'avenir
64 ans après la déclaration schuman 57
ans après le traité de rome
c'est ans après le traité de lisbonne il
faut continuer à transformer l'europe
l'histoire des peuples est en marche les
européens depuis la rome antique on
construit une identité mais aussi une
histoire commune avec ses 28 membres
l'europe est indéniablement unis mais
construction a besoin de transformation
et d'adaptation
en politique il s'agit de réformes de
réalise et aussi de courage monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'europe
n'est pas une construction de l'esprit
c'est un grand dessein qui demande de la
patience de l'énergie mais surtout de
l'audace celle d'aller de l'avant je
vous remercie de votre attention
comme la suite du débat la parole est un
monsieur dominique bailly en rappeur du
groupe socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
mes chers collègues dimanche 400
millions de citoyens européens
seront appelés aux urnes pour renouveler
le parlement il ne s'agit pas d'une
simple élection le choix que les
citoyens européens feront déterminera
l'avenir de la construction européenne
oui en effet qu'est l'europe voulons
nous quelles perspectives pour l'union
européenne
je pense qu'il est primordial de
réaffirmé dimanche notre ambition notre
volonté politique pour la construction
européenne ne laissons pas les
eurosceptiques
démanteler le projet européen que nous
construisons qui se construit pas à pas
pas à pas depuis plus de 50 ans
l'élection du 25 mai est une nouvelle
étape de la construction européenne
puisque pour la première fois les 7 les
741 députés du parlement du nouveau
parlement désigneront le président de la
commission européenne oui en venant
voter le 25 mai les citoyens européens
donneront du poids au parlement européen
pour peser sur les décisions futures
mais aussi ils auront pour la première
fois leur mot à dire je l'évoquais à
l'instant sur le choix du président de
la commission qui devra être issu des
rangs de la majorité dégagé dimanche
prochain d'ailleurs le 15 mai a eu lieu
oui peut-être dans l'indifférence le
premier débat présidentiel pour l'europe
certains journalistes je les sites ont
même évoqué la naissance de la
démocratie européenne
alors l'europe pourra bientôt dimanche
s'appuyer sur une légitimité
démocratique qui lui fait défaut bien
sûr que ça lui fait défaut mais leur a
pas besoin d'un nouvel élan
les politiques d'austérité voulues et
mise en oeuvre par la droite européenne
oui la droite européenne sont
responsables de la défiance des citoyens
vis-à-vis de cette union
il nous faut donc sortir de l'austérité
de ce discours et montrer aux citoyens
européens qu'une autre europe est
possible une europe qui protège une
europe du progrès d'ailleurs le
président de la république françois
hollande oeuvre oui depuis deux ans dans
ce sens comme l'attestent d'ailleurs les
batailles gagnées sur la garantie
jeunesse en particulier ou encore sur
les travailleurs détachés oui je veux
saluer ici l'adoption par le parlement
européen de la directive d'applications
sur le détachement des travailleurs
c'est une avancée peut-être légère mais
c'est une avancée et l'action du
gouvernement français monsieur le
ministre a été décisive pour trouver un
accord entre les états membres et le
parlement européen on sait très bien que
tout cela n'est pas simple et cette
directive permettra une lutte plus
efficace contre les fraudes et le
dumping social parce qu'elle prévoit le
renforcement des contrôles grâce et une
liste ouverte de documents permettant à
chaque état membre d'exiger des
entreprises des documents qu'il estime
utiles et nécessaires afin de vérifier
que les règles soient respectées dans le
cadre d'un détachement de travailleurs
elle prévoit aussi c'est écrit la
responsabilisation des entreprises
donneuses d'ordre vis-à-vis de leurs
sous traitants grâce à la mise en place
d'un mécanisme de responsabilité
conjointe et solidaire obligatoire dans
tous les états membres il sera donc
désormais possible d'établir une chaîne
de responsabilités au niveau européen ce
qui n'était pas le cas pour lutter
contre ces montages frauduleux cette
directive permet aussi l'établissement
d'une liste de critères permettant à
chaque état membre d'accueil
d'identifier une vraie situation de
détachement est aussi le renforcement de
la coopération et l'échangé
d'informations sur le détachement de
travailleurs entre les états membres cet
accord est un progrès peut être léger
aux yeux de certains mais c'est un
progrès et nous montrent que l'europe
peut apporter de réponses concrètes
c'est cela que nous demandent nos
concitoyens pour protéger les droits des
travailleurs contre le dumping social en
particulier oui mes chers collègues le
modèle social européen ne doit pas être
une utopie ne doit pas être une les
traités actuels contiennent d'ailleurs
des dispositions qui doivent être
améliorés bien sûr mais qui assure des
droits sociaux aujourd'hui aux citoyens
européens mais les dirigeants
aujourd'hui libéraux et conservateurs
qui gouvernent l'europe ont toujours
privilégié les politiques d'austérité
voilà le problème est donc pour donner
du corps à l'europe sociale le premier
enjeu est donc la mise en oeuvre
effective des textes qui existent déjà
aujourd'hui pour le développement des
droits sociaux au niveau européen par la
voie législative dans des domaines où
cela est déjà possible en décembre 2013
oui mon cher collègue j'ai eu l'occasion
d'intervenir du débat préalable au
conseil européen sur l'approfondissement
de l'union économique et monétaire uem
j'avais alors souligné la nécessité de
développer la dimension sociale de cette
union comme le défend le gouvernement
français d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre
via la mise en oeuvre d'un budget
spécifique pour la zone euro et d'un
dispositif chômage européenne ce qui
n'était à l'époque qu'une proposition
presque marginal est aujourd'hui de plus
en plus prise au sérieux et relayée par
de nombreux politiques et économistes
d'ailleurs la lutte contre les
inégalités et la poursuite du modèle
social européen sont l'avenir de
l'europe ouais des études montrent en
effet les bénéfices économiques et
sociaux de la lutte contre les
inégalités une telle politique
contribuerez non seulement à rétablir le
contact entre l'europe et ses citoyens
mais réduire est aussi considérablement
le risque d'une nouvelle crise
économique
oui l'assurance chômage européenne
permettrait de remplir l'objectif de
stabilisation
macroéconomique dévolu à la capacité
budgétaire de la zone euro en effet les
dépenses liées au chômage étant
particulièrement cif cycliques et oui
l'assurance-chômage européenne
contribuerait également à réduire la
tendance à faire des politiques sociales
variable d'ajustement des et faire des
efforts pardon macroéconomique en cas de
chocs asymétriques et enfin cette
assurance chômage européenne offrirait
enfin une visibilité forte auprès des
citoyens qui percevrait immédiatement
les avantages sociaux de ces zone euro
la construction européenne pour regagner
en légitimité a besoin monsieur le
ministre de projets qui apportent des
réponses aux difficultés des citoyens
dans des domaines qui les concerne au
plus près et l'europe à de vente elle de
nombreux combats à mener instaurer un
salaire minimum européen défini en
fonction du niveau de vie de chaque état
membre égal à au moins 60 % du salaire
médian du pays c'est du concret c'est
une priorité pour lutter contre la
précarité et limiter le dumping social
et accroître la justice sociale garantir
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
sur les plan salarial économiques
sociales et politiques
lutter encore et toujours contre le
dumping social lors de cette nouvelle
législature les droits sociaux les
libertés économiques doivent être placés
sur un plan d'égalité
combattre le chômage des jeunes pour que
la jeunesse européenne oui ne soit pas
la génération perdue une génération
perdue et les propositions ne manquent
pas dans ce domaine renforcement de la
40e' jeunesse adoption la cat de qualité
sur les stages ou encore aides à la
mobilité étudiante et garantir à
l'ensemble des européens un accès à
l'alimentation à la santé et à l'énergie
et bien sûr oui bien sûr protéger les
services publics ce ne sont là que
quelques exemples pêcheurs collègues de
ce que pourrait de ce que doit être
l'europe alors oui monsieur jean pierre
chevènement ne laissons pas l'europe
s'essouffler redonnant du coeur à cette
construction européenne à sens prend des
concitoyens merci de votre attention
dans la suite du débat à la parole est à
monsieur roland vs pour le groupe
socialiste
ce président ce ministre mes chers
collègues
du 22 au 25 mai prochain
507 millions de citoyens sont invités à
se rendre aux urnes pour élire leurs
députés européens
depuis soit 1979 vous le savez le
parlement européen a été élu au suffrage
universel et chaque citoyen donc en
principe la possibilité d'exprimer sa
vision de l'europe hélas
demain
vraisemblablement tous ne le feront pas
loin s'en faut
beaucoup en effet s'abstiendront pour
l'europe est aujourd'hui d'abord source
d'indifférence
d'autres nombreux aussi ils ont ce
scrutin pour exprimer leurs inquiétudes
et aussi pourquoi ne pas le dire leur
défiance
et autres encore s'exprimant pour l'une
ou l'autre des forces politiques qui
ensemble au cours de l'histoire on bâtit
l'union pour cela pour cela seulement
devrais je dire l'europe apparaît encore
dans une certaine mesure
synonyme d'espoir et d'espérance
d'espoir c'était déjà le sentiment qui
anime et les pères fondateurs de l'union
ces derniers en travaillant dès
l'après-guerre à je cite l'établissement
d'une communauté économique qui
introduit le ferment d'une communauté
plus large reprendre les termes de
robert schuman espéré m a jamais un
terme aux conflits qui ont émaillé
l'histoire de l'europe et construire un
continent
équilibré et prospère sur le plan
économique
l'espérance c'était celle de bâtir un
projet politique donc qui dépassant les
difficultés les vicissitudes de
l'histoire
permettra un jour à un allemand et un
français se considérer non comme des
ennemis irréductibles
et bien comme des partenaires
imaginer construire ensemble des
passerelles qui relie bien sûr à la
passerelle des deux rives qui relie
strasbourg à kehl le permettrais plutôt
que l'émir des murs qui séparent d'unir
leurs armes et cantonais 1 mais mini les
partager une même monnaie
mes chers collègues dans ma ville
strasbourg siège du conseil de l'europe
de la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme et du parlement européen chacun
mesure bien peut être plus qu'ailleurs
en france
l'extraordinaire chemin que l'europe a
parcouru en plus de 60 ans
mais chacun sait aussi que l'union
européenne est aujourd'hui à la croisée
des chemins et qu'à ce titre ces
élections européennes à venir au sein
d'un parlement qui jamais dans son
histoire ne s'était vu conférer autant
de compétences par notre était présente
un enjeu décisif celui de l'avenir de
notre continent à l'avenir questionné au
travers de l'orientation des politiques
communautaires qui l'encensent à l'union
car mes chers collègues ce ministre
depuis 2008 et la crise financière qui
qui peut raisonnablement nier que
l'idéal européen cet abîme et dans sa
réalisation politique qui peut constater
contesté que la recherche du progrès ce
soit trop souvent évanoui dans la
poursuite aveugle de grands équilibres
macroéconomiques
que l'europe s'est faite en réalité sans
ces peuples car qui peut ignorer enfin
et cris de colère des indignés dirigé
non pas contre l'europe elle-même mais
le plus souvent en faveur d'une autre
europe où aussi bien sûr en direction
des nations qui aujourd'hui constitue
cette europe dans cette défiance dans
ses doutes qui s'expriment et qui
constituent le terreau fertile à la
montée des extrêmes
c'est l'europe qu'on interroge mais
c'est aussi mes chers collègues l'europe
qui s'interrogent et pour répondre à ces
interrogations
un premier impératif s'impose remettre
le citoyen au coeur du projet européen
car c'est bien de cela qu'il s'agit
convaincre que le seul projet européen
qui vaille est celui qui se construit
avec et surtout pour les citoyens alors
cette ambition est grande elle nous
oblige et nous oblige en premier lieu à
rompre avec une vision minimal de
l'europe comme l'a exprimé le président
la république dans sa tribune publiée
dans le monde le 9 mai dernier
la vision d'une europe sur le site
commercial un politique qui ne voient en
elle qu'un marché qu'un espace monétaire
sans gouvernance qu'une somme de règles
effet de l'union une entité sans âme et
sans autre projet que celui d'accueillir
les candidats qui frappent à sa porte
une vision minimale trop strictement
économique à laquelle en tant que
socialistes et sociaux démocrates
il nous faut donc opposé cette europe
des peuples ce plus plus nécessaire que
jamais aujourd'hui et pour construire
cette europe des peuples j'ai la
conviction qu'une évolution majeure
s'impose celle de la nécessité d'un
approfondissement du débat démocratique
au sein de nos institutions
or on le sait la crise économique a
profondément bouleversé les équilibres
institutionnels européens
modifié en quelque sorte le centre de
gravité de l'édifice européen en
précipitant sur le devant de la scène
politique des institutions centrales
comme la commission européenne où la
banque centrale européenne dont les
orientations politiques retenues échappe
en réalité au débat démocratique
or comment vouloir raisonnablement faire
accepter aux citoyens européens des
décisions politiques parfois
douloureuses prises par des institutions
situées en dehors de l'espace
délibératif pourquoi ne pas ouvrir le
débat démocratique comme le fait le
gouvernement français sur les choix en
matière de politique monétaires opérés
par là banque centrale quand ceux ci on
le sait détermine si directement le
destin économique des états et des
populations
car mes chers collègues il ne faut pas
se tromper d'ailleurs un principe
d'indépendance conférer aux institutions
par notre était derrière le voile je
dirais de la décision technique prise au
nom de l'intérêt supérieur du projet
européen ce sont bien des décisions
politiques au sens plein du terme que
prennent les institutions de l'europe de
bruxelles comme j'aime à la plaie est à
mon sens il importe qu'une plus grande
transparence démocratique puisse
s'appliquer aussi à ces dernières les
chers collègues depuis 1979 je le disais
tous les citoyens européens peuvent
voter et ainsi exprimer leur vision de
l'europe mais demain tous ne le ferons
pas car beaucoup en réalité s'interroge
sur la pertinence de leur vote tel est
en effet le problème central non pas
seulement que les citoyens se détournent
des élections parlementaires européennes
mais bien que la politique elle-même se
détourne d'une certaine manière du
parlement européen et face à ce constat
nous allons franchir je m'en félicite
une première étape dans le renforcement
de la légitimité politique de la
commission en effet à l'occasion de
cette campagne cela a été dit les
principaux partis politiques présentent
pour la première fois leur candidat à la
présidence de la commission l'objectif
avoué étant de personnaliser le débat
pour politiser ce choix de même le
parlement européen a proposé en avril
dernier que le plus grand nombre
possible de commissaire européen soit
choisi parmi les députés nouvellement
élus il faut la saluer une première
avancée démocratique notable est
nécessaire nécessaire mais non encore
suffisante car les chantiers
démocratique demeure nombreux
et mes chers collègues ont terminé sans
vouloir me livrer à la critique
populiste du gouvernement des juges j'ai
pour ma part était particulièrement
intérêt interpellé par la récente
décision de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne
remettant en cause l'existant semaine
des epic au prétexte je cite qu'il
bénéficierait d'une garantie financière
implicite illimitée si les commentaires
sont partagés sur l'impact réel de cette
décision il n'en demeure pas moins qu en
rendant des décisions de ce type la cour
de justice européenne produit des effets
politiques qui parfois je pense par
exemple au droit du travail participe
d'une remise en cause de nos modèles
sociaux et tout cela malheureusement ne
peut qu éloignés les citoyens de
l'europe
oui mais on voit bien à travers cet
exemple concret que la frontière est
poreuse entre d'une part la proche
technocratique et juridique et d'autre
part la proche politique des grands
dossiers européens il ne faudrait pas
que je reconnais que la construction
européenne dont nous rêvons s'enlise
chaque jour un peu plus dans le
juridisme au détriment de la dimension
politique et citoyenne sans laquelle
l'europe risque de n'être qu'un machin
sans avenir c'est aussi là un des enjeux
des élections dimanche prochain à
l'europe technocratique dont le siège
est largement à bruxelles je vous invite
mes chers collègues a opposé l'europe
citoyenne dont le siège est à strasbourg
je vous remercie de votre attention
dans la suite du débat la parole et à me
faire même désir secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
européennes monsieur le rapporteur
pierre bernard reymond mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je tiens
monsieur le rapporteur à vous remercier
ainsi que la commission des affaires
européennes du sénat pour le travail de
très grande qualité que vous avez
conduit ainsi que pour les réflexions
très riche et dense et des propositions
que vous avez rassemblé dans ce rapport
cette contribution au débat européen est
aussi monsieur le rapporteur je le sais
la somme de vos expériences de la
relation intime que vous avez toujours
entretenu avec la cause européenne de la
parfaite connaissance de ces arcanes que
vous avez affirmé à travers les
différentes fonctions que vous avez
assumé que ce soit en tant que
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes parlementaires européens ou
sénateur je dois dire d'ailleurs que
l'orientation générale qui se dégage de
votre rapport par de nombreux aspects
celle que ses forces rejoint celle que
s'efforce de promouvoir le gouvernement
auquel j'appartiens nous en partageons
le diagnostic vous l'appelez le
crépuscule le besoin d'un nouvel élan
nous l'appelons la crise et le besoin de
poursuivre la réorientation de la
construction européenne est de relancer
le projet européen mais nous partageons
à l'évidence une même conviction
européenne une même ambition pour
l'europe une même certitude que l'europe
n'est pas la source de nos problèmes
mais un élément de la solution pour
répondre aux défis de notre temps et à
ce que doit relever notre pays vous avez
rappelé comme d'autres orateurs les
accomplissements de l'europe la paix la
réunification du continent les valeurs
de la démocratie de solidarité de
cohésion et les défis qu'elle a relevé
dans la mondialisation des sensibilités
différentes peuvent naturellement
s'exprimer quant aux voies et moyens à
emprunter pour réaliser ses objectifs
mais en tout état de cause le sénat peut
s'honorer d'avoir inscrit un tel débat à
son ordre du jour et j'en remercie
particulièrement le président sutour à
quelques jours d'élections européennes
cruciales pour l'avenir de l'europe et
de la france il permet d'éclairer nos
concitoyens sur l'importance du choix
qui vont devoir faire car l'europe ne
peut se faire sans ces peuples comme
vient de le rappeler le sénateur rice
jamais en effet cette élection du
parlement européen n'aura été aussi
importante parce que pour la première
fois cela a été rappelé par plusieurs
orateurs il existe un lien direct entre
le bulletin que nous mettrons dans
l'urne et le choix du président de la
commission européenne parce que ce vote
pèsera sur l'orientation qui sera donné
à la construction européenne pour les
cinq prochaines années parce que le
parlement européen a des pouvoirs
importants dans tous les domaines qui
concerne très directement la vie de nos
concitoyens les règles qui régissent le
marché intérieur et donc l'économie mais
aussi les services d'intérêt économique
général donc les services publics les
règles qui concernent l'environnement la
qualité de vie la scène les normes
sanitaires la lutte contre le dumping
social l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes la politique agricole nos accords
de commerce avec le reste du monde il
est donc grand temps de mettre fin à ce
curieux paradoxe qui voudrait que
l'abstention progresse alors même que
les pouvoirs du parlement européen
augmente je veux donc le dire ici avec
solennité
l'abstention est un renoncement le repli
sur soi une impasse nous devons donc
appelé à la participation la plus forte
pour que les citoyens choisissent leur
destin européen et pour que la france
pèse en europe je voudrais revenir sur
plusieurs points de votre rapport et du
débat qui vient de se dérouler en lien
avec les priorités que se fixe le
gouvernement d'abord je ne veux pas
éluder la question de l' architecture de
l'union et de ses institutions qui est
central dans votre rapport l'europe
différencier et déjà aujourd'hui une
réalité le coeur du réacteur de l'union
européenne c'est la zone euro l'espace
schengen quant à lui compte 22 membres
de l'union des coopérations renforcées
sont mises en place au cours des
dernières années que ce soit sur la
législation applicable au divorce le
brevet et plus récemment la taxe sur les
transactions financières cette europe
différencier c'est une souplesse que
nous donnons pour respecter ceux qui ne
veulent pas ou ne peuvent pas participer
à une intégration plus poussée sans pour
autant empêcher ceux qui veulent aller
de l'avant de le faire cette souplesse
est utile et respecte le rythme de
chacun mais nous devons en même temps
prendre garde à ne pas créer déjà les
germes d'une division de l'europe cela
serait préjudiciable au projet européen
dans son ensemble et donc pour cela il
nous faut faire preuve de méthode et de
rigueur et plusieurs principes doivent
il me semble nous guider d'abord cette
europe différencier ne doit pas nous
empêcher de continuer à agir à 28 chaque
fois que cela est possible et que cela
est souhaitable comme nous avons su le
faire par exemple et c'est le sénateur
bailly qui le rappelait à l'instant sur
la directive relative au détachement des
travailleurs avec en particulier le
soutien décisif de la pologne
car la lutte contre le dumping social
doit se mener à l'échelle de toute
l'europe et de l'ensemble du marché
intérieur pour être réellement efficace
de même d'autres enjeux mérite d'être
porté à 28 je pense par exemple à la
sécurité énergétique ou à la cohésion de
l'union où la cohésion de l'union dans
son ensemble est nécessaire en
particulier face aux pays tiers ensuite
cette europe différencier n'est pas et
ne doit pas être une robe fermé à ceux
qui n'y sont pas elle doit au contraire
être laissée ouverte aux autres états
membres qui souhaiteraient plus tard la
rejoindre enfin cette europe
différencier positive autour d'un projet
commun ne doit pas signifier pour
d'autres états membres une europe à la
carte qui permettrait à certains de
bénéficier des avantages des droits que
confère l'appartenance à l'union mais en
laissant de côté ce qui ne leur convient
pas en revendiquant par exemple un accès
sans limite aux marchés intérieurs des
marchandises des services des capitaux
mais en refusant la libre circulation
des citoyens de l'union sur leur
territoire procédez ainsi porterait
réellement préjudice à l'intégrité du
marché intérieur et de l'union
européenne et cela ne serait pas
acceptable au sein de notre maison
commune à 28 la france et l'allemagne
ont évidemment un rôle irremplaçable à
jouer et il le joue et je voudrais à cet
égard monsieur le sénateur vous assurer
et rassurer ceux des orateurs qui ont
évoqué l'importance du couple franco
allemand le déplacement du président de
la république dans la circonscription de
la chancelière invitation très rare tout
comme la présence de frank walter
steinmeier au dernier conseil des
ministres ont été des illustrations
forte de la densité de nos relations
j'ai moi même des relations très nourris
avec mon homologue michael roth j'en
tire d'ailleurs d'ores et déjà plusieurs
enseignements le premier c'est que la
relation franco allemande tient bien sûr
à sa singularité à celle de notre
histoire le cycle de commémoration de
2014 nous le rappelle avec force mais
cette relation qui a aussi à notre
capacité à nous projeter vers l'avenir
et à faire vivre le projet européen rien
de ce qu'il s'est fait au cours des deux
dernières années n'aurait été possible
sans désaccord solide entre la france et
l'allemagne le second c'est que cette
fonction de laboratoire de la
construction européenne nous allons la
mettre au service des défis à relever
comme l'approfondissement de l'union
économique et monétaire le soutien à la
croissance et à l'emploi la régulation
financière la lutte contre le changement
climatique
la transition énergétique ou encore la
lutte contre le dumping social nous
devons également ensemble avance et
proposer des réponses aux défis
migratoires ils ont été soulevées dans
ce débat qui appelle une réponse commune
c'est vrai en particulier après les
drames en méditerranée et notamment le
renforcement des moyens de l'agencé
frontex mais aussi une politique de
voisinage en direction du sud pour
assurer la stabilité le développement la
démocratie dans les pays du sud de la
méditerranée nos initiatives concrètes
sont autant de preuves de la capacité du
franco allemand a devrait au plus près
des préoccupations de nos concitoyens
nos propositions communes doivent aussi
se nourrir du programme ou nourrir plus
exactement le futur programme de la
nouvelle commission qui prendra place
après les élections européennes
le renouvellement des institutions
européennes crée en effet une
opportunité pour relancer la
construction européenne ce nouveau cycle
doit être celui de la consolidation de
l'ambition et du progrès notre
conviction
nous devons faire porter nos efforts sur
ces enjeux plutôt que nous nous engager
dans la voie d'une réforme
institutionnelle qui ne correspond pas
aujourd'hui aux attentes prioritaires de
nos concitoyens et qui comporte
également de nombreux risques notamment
ceux de retour en arrière ou de
multiplication des options août dans le
contexte du débat britannique sur ce
sujet il s'agit donc pas d'exclure
définitivement des évolutions mais
d'exploiter à traiter constants tous les
potentiels que les politiques
européennes peuvent encore déployé
deuxième élément l'enjeu aujourd'hui
c'est de continuer à remettre la
croissance et l'emploi au coeur du
projet européen et sur ce point je
rejoins évidemment l'insistance du
sénateur chevènement c'est bien la kz
majeur de la politique européenne de la
france l'euro qui était au bord de
l'éclatement il ya encore deux ans a été
sauvée on parlait à l'époque de la
sortie de la grèce la zone euro même si
il faut accentuer ce mouvement sort de
la récession et renoue avec la
croissance les deux premiers piliers de
l'union bancaire la supervision et la
résolution ont été lancés pour protéger
les épargnants et les contribuables leur
tour la consolidation de la croissance
sont désormais au coeur de l'agenda
européen en rupture avec la stratégie
d'austérité qui a trop longtemps dominé
en europe je veux vraiment assuré le
sénateur chevènement que c'est bien là
la priorité de la france et c'est
pourquoi dès le conseil européen de juin
2012 le président de la république
françois hollande s'est battu pour que
ce soit là l'objet de nouvelles
politiques et qu'un pacte de croissance
de 120 milliards d'euros mobilisant à la
fois de nouvelles capacités de la banque
européenne d'investissement mais aussi
des fonds structurels qui n'étaient pas
utilisés puis s'est mis au service de
projets européens communs concernant la
banque européenne d'investissement
l'augmentation de son capital de 10
milliards d'euros va permettre
d'augmenter les investissements à
l'échelle européenne soutenue par
l'abbaye de 60 milliards d'euros est
d'ores et déjà en france ans les prêts
qui était en moyenne de 4 5 milliards
d'euros par an sont passés à 7,8
milliards d'euros en 2013 résultats que
nous devons renouveler en 2014 et en
2015 il faudra aller plus loin encore en
particulier en utilisant les project
bond qui ont commencé à être mis en
oeuvre dans plusieurs pays de l'union
européenne nous voulons également
développer de nouvelles capacités à
travers le cadre financier pluriannuel
que nous avons sauvegardé en préservant
les grandes politiques européennes en
particulier la politique agricole
commune et les politiques de cohésion
tout en mettant davantage l'accent sur
les politiques d'avenir avec
l'augmentation des budgets de la
recherche de l'innovation des transports
de l'énergie mais aussi de chants
nouveaux comme celui du numérique à cet
égard je conviens bien volontiers que
nous aurions souhaité comme nombre
d'entre vous l'ont exprimé en
particulier le sénateur gâteau la un
cadre financier plus ambitieux et je
rejoins vos réflexions sur l'enjeu
central monsieur le rapporteur qui
constitue la création de nouvelles
ressources propres seule voie qui nous
permettra de débloquer durablement le
débat budgétaire européen nous suivons
donc avec une grande attention les
travaux du groupe à haut niveau qui a
été constituée au sein des institutions
européennes
enfin la proche de la consolidation
budgétaire a été infléchie et la banque
centrale européenne elle même a évolué
sous l'impulsion de mario draghi vous le
soulignez dans votre rapport
d'importantes avancées ont également été
réalisés en matière de lutte contre la
fraude et l'évasion fiscales en
particulier l'accord sur la directive
relative à la fiscalité de l'épargné
lors du conseil du 24 mars dernier le
conseil européen de mars ayant permis de
surmonter l'opposition de l'autriche et
du luxembourg en particulier sur les
changes automatique d'informations ces
évolutions sont importantes car l'on
peut à la fois tenir nos objectifs de
sérieux sur le plan budgétaire et c'est
tout le sens du pacte de responsabilité
tout en obérant pas notre capacité à
prendre le train du retour de la
croissance ces grands chantiers
doivent encore connaître des
développements importants dans les
prochains mois sur l'union bancaire
suite à l'accord sur les textes seraient
relatifs aux mécanismes de résolution
unique le conseil devra adopter cet été
un acte d'exécution pour répartir entre
les banques européennes leur
contribution à la constitution du fonds
de résolution à moyen terme il nous
faudra également doté l'union bancaire
de son troisième pilier avec un
mécanisme européen de garantie des
dépôts pour aller au bout de notre
démarche de sécurisation et de
régulation sur le renforcement de la
zone euro le sénateur young et plusieurs
d'entre vous y ont assisté nous
souhaitons également une gouvernance
renforcée avec un président stable c'est
une de vos propositions une dimension
parlementaire car il faut renforcer le
contrôle démocratique de ce noyau dur de
l'union européenne mais aussi à terme
une capacité financière comme l'a
proposé le président de la république
vos réflexions et les notes sont
convergentes sur ce point cette
gouvernance rénovée permettra de
réaliser en particulier la feuille de
route que nous souhaitons pour un
soutien plus fort aux investissements à
la croissance mais aussi à la
convergence sociale et fiscale au sein
de la zone euro sur la taxe sur les
transactions financières qui va pouvoir
entrer en application dans un premier
temps à l'échelle de 10 pays d'ici au
1er janvier 2016 et qui portera à la
fois sur les transactions des actions
mais aussi sur certains produits dérivés
sur le partenariat commercial
transatlantique sujet qui a été
mentionnée par la sénatrice de messine
et plusieurs d'entre vous qui doit
permettre à nos entreprises à nos
agriculteurs
d'accéder à un marché qui leur est
souvent fermée le marché américain mais
en même temps dans des conditions et
nous sommes très attentifs à la
négociation qui est en cours qui ne
remettent pas en cause les normes
européennes en matière de protection des
consommateurs des consommateurs en
matière
sociale sanitaire environnementale et
nous sommes favorables nous l'avons dit
à la plus grande transparence
je sais que la sénatrice
nicole bricq lorsqu'elle était au
gouvernement en charge de ce dossier
s'était également exprimé dans ce sens
car les parlements comme les différentes
parties prenantes économiques et
sociales doivent évidemment puisqu'elles
sont directement concernés pouvoir
suivre le déroulement de cette
négociation et je veux rappeler que les
parlements des 28 états membres de même
que le parlement européen auront
évidemment à se prononcer et à ratifier
l'accord à l'issue de la négociation et
que donc c'est bien au parlement que
reviendra le dernier mot nous devons
aussi veiller à la mise en oeuvre rapide
des grandes politiques européennes je
sais que la haute assemblée il est
particulièrement sensible je pense en
particulier aux contrats qui sont en
train d'être
discuté à la commission européenne qui
ont été transmis par nos régions pour
l'utilisation des fonds structurels
concernant cette priorité à la
croissance
je veux également vous dire que la
présidence italienne qui commencera le
1er juillet va constituer une
opportunité à saisir et j'ai bien
mesurer sa disponibilité son ambition
lors de mon déplacement à rome le 23
avril dernier à ce titre le conseil
européen d'octobre qui est
traditionnellement dédiée aux questions
économiques sera un rendez vous très
importants figurent à l'agenda la
question des contrats de partenariats et
des mécanismes de solidarité associés
mais la présidence italienne voudrais
surtout en faire un conseil européen
tournée vers l'économie réelle et c'est
là une priorité que nous rejoignons ce
sera donc là la bonne occasion pour
revenir sur les enjeux industriels qui
ont été soulevées par la sénatrice de
messine que vous traitez également de
votre rapport pour avoir un véritable
plan d'action permettant de faire
remonter la part de l'industrie à 20% du
pib européen en veillons donc pour ce
faire à bien prendre en compte dans
toutes les politiques européennes cette
priorité et je pense en particulier à la
politique de la concurrence et à la
politique commerciale cette présidence
sera également l'occasion de prolonger
l'action engagée dans des secteurs clés
comme le numérique il a été mentionné ou
la défense sujet qui ont déjà été
l'objet de débats du conseil européen
sur
l'énergie précisément qui est un sujet
que vous traitez également je pense que
il s'agit là d'un enjeu majeur et le
président bizet comme la sénatrice mélo
ils ont assisté ce sujet a été à l'ordre
du jour du dernier conseil européen il
le sera à nouveau en juin la crise du
crédit yen soulignent davantage encore
l'enjeu stratégique des questions
énergétiques pour l'union européenne et
l'impérieuse nécessité de bâtir une
véritable union énergétique celle ci
doit également nous permettre de traiter
les enjeux du changement climatique les
questions énergétiques et climatiques
concerne tous les pays de l'union et
tous les européens elles ont un impact
direct sur le quotidien de nos
concitoyens et nos entreprises ainsi que
sur nos économies et la capacité de
notre société à préparer l'avenir
les travaux du conseil s'articule
actuellement autour de trois enjeux la
préparation d'un accord cadre pour le
climat post 2020 à l'horizon donc 2030
sur la base des propositions transmises
par la commission européenne le 22
janvier qui vise à réduire de 40% les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et à
porter la part des renouvelables à 27%
cela implique de bien évaluer les
conséquences pour chaque état membre de
sa corte s'accorder sur le partage de
l'effort de prendre des mesures pour
éviter les fuites de carbone et
d'assurer la compétitivité de nos
industries énergivores il faut donc à
partir de juillet revoir en particulier
la directive sur l'efficacité
énergétique la préparation d'objectifs
spécifiques
d'interconnexion sujet qui a évidemment
pris une importance particulière dans le
contexte de la crise ukrainienne
l'adoption d'un plan d'action en matière
de sécurité et de dépendance énergétique
vous le savez les pistes explorées porte
sur des mesures d'efficacité énergétique
sur la diversification des sources
d'approvisionnement et des routes sur le
renforcement des interconnexions sur des
mécanismes de solidarité et d'achats
groupés sur une nouvelle approche de la
dimension externe de la politique
énergétique européenne et sur les
ressources indigènes c'est dans ce
contexte que les échanges entre le
président de la république et le premier
ministre polonais ont permis
d'enregistrer une avancée qui sera
formalisée dans les prochaines semaines
mais je voudrais insister sur deux
points qui me paraissent devoir être
souligné d'abord nous voulons que le
conseil européen de juin ne soit pas
simplement une étape procédurale
mais l'occasion d'un vrai débat de fond
au plan politique entre les états
membres sur la base des éléments demandé
à la commission et au conseil en mars
c'est indispensable pour être à même de
décider au plus tard en octobre et pour
pouvoir envoyer un signal clair dès le
sommet convoqué par le secrétaire
général des nations unies à new york en
septembre
et vous savez que nous avons de ce point
de vue un rendez vous majeur sur le plan
international qui est celui de la coop
21 qui se tiendra à paris en 2015 et il
faut donc que l'europe avant cette
conférence mondiale puisse être en
mesure d'avoir pris ses propres
décisions en matière de lutte contre le
changement climatique
ensuite sur le fond l'actualité a mis en
lumière l'enjeu de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et nous devons
naturellement y répondre avec toute la
détermination nécessaires mais nous
devons être clairs et nous devons l'être
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de nos
partenaires et des états membres les
mesures que nous prendrons ne pourront
être pleinement efficaces que si elles
s'inscrivent dans une stratégie
énergétique globale fondée sur la
transition vers une économie sobre en
carbone et de ce point de vue il n'ya
pas à choisir entre climat et sécurité
énergétique ce serait absurde pour nous
la sécurité d'approvisionnement
énergétique de l'ue eux et le cadre
énergie climat 2000 tentes forment un
seul et même paquet les deux volets se
renforcent mutuellement ainsi les
efforts réalisés pour lutter contre le
changement climatique nous aideront à
réduire à la fois notre dépendance
vis-à-vis des grands pays producteurs
d'hydrocarbures et la facture
énergétique qui pèse sur nos entreprises
et sur nos concitoyens
quatrième point enfin que je voudrais
évoquer rapidement pour conclure c'est
celui de l'europe de la défense
vous y avait là aussi fait référence
ainsi que la sénatrice mélo les derniers
mois ont montré son actualité et la
nécessité pour l'europe de se doter
d'une véritable politique étrangère et
de défense commune la mise en oeuvre des
conclusions du causse du conseil
européen des 19 et 20 décembre dernier
doit donc être notre priorité des
mandats ont été donnés aux institutions
européennes des calendriers ont été
clairement énoncés nous devons veiller
ensemble à ce que les différentes
échéances qui ont été fixés soit
respectée cela est vrai naturellement
pour les actions qui sont en cours dans
différents théâtres d'opération en
particulier en afrique et nous devons
souligner que nos partenaires se sont
engagés à nos côtés notamment dans
l'opération de formation de l'armée
malienne mais aussi dans l'opération
eufor rca la brigade franco-allemande
est également mobilisée au mali mais ces
avancées doivent également se traduire
dans le domaine des capacités dans celui
de la mutualisation de la coopération
qui sont aujourd'hui les seules voies
réaliste en matière de développement
capacitaire je pense tout
particulièrement aux drones et aux
avions ravitailleurs il y a évidemment
une dimension industrielle de partage de
nos capacités de nos savoir faire qui
est indispensable pour faire naître
cette europe de la défense et pour
garantir l'autonomie stratégique des
européens ainsi que la croissance et
l'emploi dans ces industries ce sont me
semble-t-il les principales priorités
qui doivent figurer au coeur de nos
travaux afin de bien assurer le suivi de
ce que le conseil européen a décidé tout
ceci mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
est évidemment au service de la mise en
oeuvre d'une grande ambition de la
france pour une europe plus forte plus
prospère et plus solidaire et si nos
objectifs et nos actions ne recoupe pas
la totalité de vos propositions monsieur
le rapporteur vous voyez bien que nous
allons dans la même direction j'entends
comme vous mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs nos concitoyens qui nous
disent ne pas percevoir dans leur
quotidien tous les bénéfices de ces
réalisations j'entends aussi ceux de nos
compatriotes qui se plaignent d'un
divorce entre l'europe et les citoyens
parce que notre projet ne parle plus
évidemment la langue commune ou ne fixe
plus un cap clair c'est à cela aussi que
votre rapport s'adresse et c'est vers
cela aussi que je veux me tourner je
veux leur témoigner de notre
détermination à avancer en suivant un
cap clair résolu dans la poursuite de la
construction européenne de l'unité
européenne mais aussi de la
réorientation européennes vers la
croissance vers l'emploi vers les
priorités des citoyens car servir
l'europe avec de grandes ambitions comme
vous le proposez et comme nous le
faisons c'est non seulement servir une
belle et grande idée un beau projet pour
notre continent
mais c'est aussi la meilleure façon de
servir la france ses valeurs son
influence et son poids dans le monde de
demain je vous remercie
voilà pour ce débat consacré au projet
européen qui s'étonnait donc hier après
midi dans l'hémicycle du sénat je vous
rappelle que dimanche prochain dimanche
25 mai vont se tenir les élections
européennes que pour la première fois le
scrutin sera pris en compte pour
désigner le président de la commission
européenne qui sera élu par le parlement
aujourd'hui encore le sénat continue à
parler d'europe cet après midi en
consacrant un débat sur le climat et
l'énergie vous pouvez toujours re voir
toutes les séances sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
pour 24 arsenal audition avec notamment
une audition de louis gallois très bonne
fin de journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires